good morning it's uh past 10 o'clock I'm
going to go ahead and open the uh the
work session on uh Patricia Tilley's
money
uh otherwise referred to as public
health
I'm going to pass the gavel to
representative Mooney for a while while
I go tie my tie and get my things I I'm
late today sorry
excellent Miss Tilly
first of all before we begin anything
for the good of the order among our
division III members all right I believe
we'll probably have a handout book
coming up and we'll know what page to
start on so we can follow along
chairwoman Mooney yeah I will be leaving
at 11 30 to introduce a bill so I just
wanted to excuse my absence at that time
thank you very much and good luck with
that thank you
good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services and I'm joined
here today with
good morning everyone my name is
Patricia Tilley I'm the director of
Public Health thank you
um now before you
um we have provided two documents uh one
is the PowerPoint presentation similar
to the others that you've seen and then
we have also provided the budget
briefing book that includes the
um the detailed account information for
the accounts in excess of one million
dollars
if you turn to the governor's
recommended budget it's on page 939 is
where the division of Public Health
Services begins and with that I will
hand the presentation over to Trisha
Tilley thank you Mr White welcome Ms
Tilly thank you good morning everyone so
thank you for the opportunity to walk
through our Public Health budget in
order for any State Health Department to
support and protect the communities we
serve we need sufficient resources to
respond to both state and local priority
about a few challenges that we face then
we're going to dive into the many many
accounting units that are in public
health I have about 40 something slides
and a 90 page budget briefing book it's
a lot
um it for the most part it will be just
Nathan and I at the table today but we
have our deputy director Ian watt who's
sitting in the back and our Public
Health finance manager Shelly Swanson in
case you stump us with a question that
we can't answer they can back us up they
can phone a friend we will be able to
get the information that you need so my
goal for the next few hours is to go
through the budgets give you a high
level overview with the opportunity to
pause dig deep in any areas of interest
that you might have so um we have a
slide deck here if we flip to slide two
our mission and vision on this slide
represents the ways in both large and
small that our work how our work is
designed to prevent the spread of
disease and help people stay healthy
that's sort of all of it in a nutshell
and we do that in partnership with
policy makers and communities and our
core functions are not new as the
archives that sit outside my office
indicate we've been doing a lot of it as
a function of state government for well
over a hundred years years counting
things keeping track of Health Data
inspecting milk food make sure it was
healthy using our laboratory to diagnose
disease and contain outbreaks and
ensuring that there are safety nets for
pregnant women and infants and that we
address environmental hazards that
impact Health more recently Public
Health has been on the front page of the
newspaper for the past three years
throughout the pandemic many of you may
have gotten sick of us along the way but
I hope that we have time to talk about
the million other ways other than covid
that we use state and federal resources
to put this Mission and these values
into practice and in fact today is my
day of props I have with me as sort of
my backup this book right here is from
1882 it is the first published Public
Health Report that sits outside my desk
I have about a hundred of these that sit
out there that are really fascinating so
um it's like there's my little backup
here to keep to keep me grounded so on
slide three at the broadest level you're
going to see the 10 essential services
that provide a framework for all that we
do from assessing and monitoring
population health status to
investigating diagnosing addressing
health concerns and problems to
improving our work through ongoing
research and and quality improvement on
slide four we put a little bit of a
finer point on it this gives a couple of
additional examples of what we do and
how it fits into those 10 essential
services and responsibilities if we
start with protection this includes our
incredibly capable emergency response
functions all the way and then sort of
spreads all the way to things like food
safety inspections not only of
restaurants but things like dairy farms
and and milk distribution
we look to Scientific evidence to inform
our strategies this is where in places
like chronic disease prevention excels
we know how to do things like diabetes
self-management and we know that there
are effective supports to help people
stop smoking not only to improve
people's lives but also to save the
state money in places like Medicaid and
long-term care supports prevention is
really at the heart of almost everything
that we do whether that's to ensure that
we have strong primary care and public
health infrastructure or ensuring that
all kids and all families have access to
Childhood vaccines you're going to hear
a lot about data as we go through our
budgets and our programs the numbers are
behind everything that we do and I hope
you've spent some time on the DHHS data
portal I've talked about it a lot at
other times we've met or that you've had
an opportunity to read important reports
that we've put out for example this year
we have a report around our our
investigation of excess rates of kidney
cancer in Merrimack very important work
that we do in partnership with our
friends at the Department of
Environmental Services as well as
through multiple areas within the
division of Public Health and finally
again it's all about improving Health
outcomes whether it is preventing
adverse childhood experiences or using
quality improvement methods to make sure
our preventative screening programs are
timely and that they actually improve
outcomes so if you slide to slide five
this is where you know this is sort of
the ultimate this is when we talk about
health outcomes and data everything
rolls up to morbidity and mortality we
had an opportunity to look at the slide
when I came earlier for our pre-hearing
this one has the added 2022 data it is
preliminary it's got a little asterisk
because death data takes a little bit
while to become complete but it's pretty
close is you know my scientific way of
saying that can we take a pause or for a
question representative
thank you chairman would you like to
take questions now or at the end first
slide on the first leg right ahead okay
so on slide four right you mentioned
vaccines for children yes
and I noticed that
um on Facebook there's still ads running
for coveted vaccines for children
um is that something you guys are still
pushing
um I
the word that I would use to
characterize it we want to make sure
that it is available to anyone who wants
it okay sorry advertising there may be a
little bit of political bias in the term
pushing
um
there seems to be compelling evidence in
in the case of children right under
under those under the age of 18 that the
adverse effects are significant and the
relative risk of covid is is very very
low based on the data that's on the on
the dashboard
would we better be better spent using
that money elsewhere so I think
primarily if you've seen some of our
sponsored links on Facebook they're
really mostly focused at individuals 50
and up that is the target group that we
are advertising to right now because
those are as you know the folks that
have the highest risk of morbidity we
have lost children we have lost young
adults in this state there have been
deaths that are covid related among
young children nowhere near the scale of
those that are older
um we just want to make sure that
coveted vaccines are available to those
people that want them
and so drilling down a little further
um we do know that Healthy Lifestyles
right proper nutrition are things that
are the best defense against some of
these particular diseases
does it not make more sense to spend
that same dollars promoting things like
reducing obesity
eating healthy cutting out sugar getting
exercise sunlight Vitamin D the list
goes on sure you know I think as we go
through this budget look you'll see that
we spend lots of resources and quite
frankly could spend even more if those
resources were made available to us in
doing those preventative activities so
you know things like our chronic disease
programs are really focused not only on
adult things like diabetes
self-management sort of which is when
the horse is out of the barn I think is
the the phrase but also on ensuring that
kids have access to a water bottle
filler
sorry thank you I'm pretty loud so I I
also just want to add some context I I
think the marketing uh that you saw on
Facebook my understanding is that's
probably paid for the federal money that
came through the fiscal committee and
that the fiscal committee green lit the
program on the understanding that this
was making it available and not
recommending that healthy kids get the
covid injection that is correct thank
you representative Edwards that is
correct and quite frankly the majority
of again some of those sponsored posts
if you look at them are really aimed at
older adults
thank you
so we can go to slide five which is
um you know sort of at the core of what
we do which is the things you die of in
New Hampshire
um and everywhere else the added as I
noted we added preliminary 2022 data
when we last met I talked about the fact
that kovid has actually probably slipped
down
um over the past few years in 2020 it
was the fourth leading cause of death in
the state in 2021 it was the third
leading cause of death in the state and
by 2022 it looks like it's going to slip
down to about the fifth leading cause of
death which actually is lower than
probably the rest of the country again
all the states haven't landed on those
final numbers because death data takes a
little bit longer what what I will
representative
thank you do you have a graph that shows
comparison of all-cause mortality over
the past few years
are you are this is the list of all of
all New Hampshire residents cause of
death 20. right but what I'm looking for
is so something that shows for each year
all the deaths one number and then that
number over like the last five years we
could put that together if you wanted
that'd be great thank you thank you
um and I I have to ask about the
covid-19 number sure
there's been a lot of discussion about
the difference between dying because of
covid and dying with covid correct it's
my understanding that by and large the
reported data is people who have died
with covid not because of covet is is
that is that accurate I I would not
suggest that that is completely accurate
New Hampshire has taken a very
conservative approach to identifying
coveted deaths over time
um we review every single death
certificate and ensure that
um it makes sense
um that the uh that Co the way in which
covet is listed others other states
um historically if if covid was
somewhere on the list or there was covid
you know um that get counted as a Cova
death we actually ensure that there was
a coven positive test as well before we
count it as a coveted death again we can
spend some time a little bit later
talking a little bit about the
epidemiology behind it but we've uh
we've been using a more conservative
method to go through review every death
certificate and ensure that kovid was
the cause of death and Elite or a
leading contributor
thank you
um other than covet on this list you'll
see things like accidents which is our
unintentional deaths which include
overdoses
um one I just want to highlight your
attention there again those numbers look
a little bit low at this point we've
certainly all heard the media and have
worked with the office of the chief
medical examiner to understand that that
number is going to go up over time as we
finish toxicology reports at the for the
end of calendar year 2022. this is very
concerning to all of us and it is an
example of a place that Public Health
Works hand in hand with our division of
Behavioral Health and with Partners
across state agencies and in communities
to really address this issue of opioid
related or unintentional deaths along
the way everything else has remained
fairly static over time heart disease
cancer chronic lower respiratory disease
that's really emphysema COPD asthma as
well as stroke
so representative poll has another
question thank you under accidents right
including overdoses my understanding is
the overdoses were somewhere like 400 to
500 round numbers is it time to break
that out as a separate category
um yes it is an accidental death I get
that yeah but it's a significant portion
of that accidental death
and it some cases has direct ties back
to either surroundings lifestyle
um mental health a bunch of other things
that are that precipitate people right
they don't necessarily want to go
overdose that's not right that's not the
plan right so since it's probably more
than half of that number is it time to
break that out as a separate category
and track it that way so I
great question
um thank you for it and I think what
we've done by de facto is pull it out
the this definition of accidental death
is our national definitions that we use
for the national Center for Health
statistics so that we can compare apples
to apples across all states but we
certainly understand the need for
breaking that out to look specifically
especially in a state like New Hampshire
to address specifically overdose deaths
related other than as compared to car
crashes or ATV crashes absolutely and
maybe you just put an asterisk there and
somehow tabulate that out it's just it's
a meaningful number considering it's
more than half of that number for each
year absolutely and and I did not
provide you the exact number with it
right now because again I know that of
all the things on the list the overdose
is probably the least complete data that
we have at this point
are there other questions
representative walner
I'm sorry I have a question about
something that isn't listed I wondered
do you have the statistics on suicide
yes so thank you I don't have that
number with me this very moment but it
does come down a little bit lower it's
usually sort of at the you know it's in
the top 10 but somewhere down at the
bottom of the top ten I've given you the
top six so the suicide number is below
you know usually I'm even gonna refrain
from just giving you the number off the
top my head I can probably find that
number for you or if Ian can find that
while I'm sitting here but um and the
thing about suicide certainly is
concerning for adult populations that's
fairly stable what we have found is the
Adolescent number sort of does this it's
a little bit Wiggly luckily it's a
relatively small number over time but it
does go up and down which is when we
look at Trends we almost have to look at
the trends over time to get a more clear
indication of whether the trend is going
up or down we really have to combine
years
yeah
great thank you so if you slide into
slide six this is how we meet all our
goals this is how public health is
organized in the upcoming and and this
is just our bureaus our uh our org chart
is sort of unwieldy which is why I
didn't put it you know do a cut and
paste you often see many of the other
divisions doing cut and paste of their
work chart our chart is pretty big so I
for the purposes today these are just
our large bureaus in the upcoming
biennium we have moved from Seven
bureaus to eight bureaus and as we go
through the budget briefing book we can
dig deeper into any of those areas
within each Bureau we are splitting the
reason we're going up a bureau is we are
splitting what is now currently known as
The Bureau population health and
community services and we're splitting
it for a couple of reasons currently it
contains all of our maternal and child
health programs our WIC program our
chronic disease and cancer prevention
programs and smoking cessation and there
is such a large number of federal grants
within that section that Bureau alone in
fact division of Public Health has the
most accounting units in the Department
of Health and Human Services the Bureau
of population health and Community
Services had the most accounting units
in the division of Public Health it's
more than almost any other area of the
department combined so we're splitting
that up for ease of administration and
really to focus some of the talent that
we have there and the leadership to
really now focus on the sort of the
young child family side and what we've
changed that into is now the Bureau of
Family Wellness and nutrition and then
we our family health and nutrition and
then the chronic disease cancer smoking
side is going to be the Bureau of
prevention and Wellness
so I will so on the surface
one could think that there's some
redundancy here because you have a
bureau that deals with Equity issues and
then and the office the commissioner we
have seven people who who deal with
Equity issues so could could you take us
a little deeper to help us understand
that there's not redundancy thank you
that's a great question and
representative so we have this bear
Health Access equity and policy really
everything that we do is infused with
the notion of equity you know we want to
make sure that we reduce Health
disparities across the board by any
groups of people and sometimes that's
racial and ethnic sometimes it's rural
non-rural sometimes it's age there's all
sorts of ways you can cut that pie when
you're looking at Health disparities in
that particular Bureau
um that has is uh is focused on Rural
health and primary care so again sort of
a rural non-rural area we also have some
equity in terms of some access to
services so our therapeutic cannabis
program is in there our pdmp is in that
program and historically
um it has also held a new uh funding
source which was our health disparities
Grant which I know representative
Edwards that you're familiar with we've
talked about that over time that was
really designed to be a large funding
source to address issues of equity so
that's very different compared to the
office of Health Equity as it's
currently standing they're doing a lot
of class standards you know making sure
communication and language access is
available to the entire department and
also I'm very excited with Reuben
Hampton who's joined that to really
provide that overall arching issue you
know sort of thought leadership around
what Health Equity looks in the
department our Bureau is much more
Hands-On and in the weeds
all right thank you
um we can scoot into slide seven then
and so here's your here's where you're
going to see just a few of the
accomplishments of our incredibly
talented team
um first of all you know again I I get
it that the rest of the world is tired
of covid
um but I do want to acknowledge the work
of that and that the work continues
behind the scenes to support things like
our long-term care facilities
um and to support hospitals trying to
keep people out of the hospital that is
the metric you know hospitalization and
death are the metrics that are North
Star around covid right now and we still
have people with covid um and we're you
know hospitals are still impacted we
were very fortunate
um that this year we did not have the
spike in the same way that we did last
year at this time we're all happy I
think
um you know a number of people would
suggest that is because of things like
vaccine
um but it is also because we've got easy
testing capability and quite frankly
Therapeutics Therapeutics have been a
game change it keeping people out of the
hospital you'll notice that also as as
earlier noted that we have some
sponsored social media posts one of
those sponsored social media posts is to
really highlight that we have a
Therapeutics program that anybody can
use to get Telehealth Services you test
positive for covid especially if you're
50 and over you can call them up get an
appointment that day on Telehealth and
get Therapeutics at your Pharmacy within
a couple of hours it's quite frankly one
of the best programs that I've had the
privilege to oversee I get random emails
all the time from the public saying
thank you for making that available my
doctor wasn't available it was Saturday
or something and I was able to get the
care that I needed right away so I just
want to highlight that as an
accomplishment of the past year I think
um the other place where we've had
significant accomplishments and and we
spoke a little bit about the last time I
was I was talking with you is really
around how we've modernized our Data
Systems we've we're worked hand in hand
with Dave Wieters and our Bureau of
Information Services with our department
of Information Technology do it and
others to modernize electronic case
reporting modernize electronic lab
reporting we've built and
operationalized our immunization
information system and our public data
portal continues to become more robust
again something that we're very proud of
a lot more work to do but we've really
moved in light years through the pan f
as a result of the pandemic in some of
our ways to report timely data and make
it a transparent to the public and
finally I'm extremely proud of the work
that we have done to support kids and
families and really focusing on
prevention you may recall last time at
this year not only where we had a spike
of covid we also had no infant formula
in the state of New Hampshire and we had
kids you know parents you know across
the board and across the economic
spectrum who who literally could not
feed their children
extraordinarily hard not only with our
WIC participants again the women infant
children feeding program to make sure
that all of those families who were
really the most vulnerable had access to
formula no matter where they were but we
were also Fielding phone calls from
regular old citizens across the state
saying where how can I access what's a
good substitution help me through this
process it was incredibly stressful for
new families last year and I am thankful
that we are done with that the Abbott
Factory is back up and running and we
are returning now to more a more regular
scope of business but again as a as a
highlight of last year's accomplishment
that's one that has been sort of quiet
because it was also during you know
covet every again the media was focused
on covid many of us were focused on the
fact that babies didn't have food to eat
so we can look at the challenges now so
those were some of the things that were
great
um I think um slide eight shows
um some of the challenges we continue to
face as we look forward to the next
biennium we know that we're going to
need to continue to address the
long-term impacts of the pandemic
primarily we have seen that the use of
preventative Services plummeted and I
think we know that we've heard that in
the media but we've seen that play out
in terms of things like a reduction in
mammograms a reduction of cervical
cancer screening a reduction in lead
screening for kids all of that has
happened over the past two years and so
we will see the impacts of that yes
so I love visual information I'm just
trying to figure out how to interpret
slide eight yeah it looks like if I were
to read it is the way I want I want to
is that the base of all of these other
things above it is that we have adverse
training and health conditions are the
colors and sequence and size of the
blocks meant to communicate about it is
that it is also scale of the problem I
don't think that one it isn't designed
to show causation or even necessarily
correlation but just really scope yeah
so this is just um relative
impact yes thank you for that question
um so again we're going to see those
adverse trending we've also seen that in
terms of Behavioral Health that is also
in all of our media feeds right now we
know the impact to adolescents we know
the impact as well to adults and we're
feeling that now so that's going to
impact all of our programs
um we continue you know if I go to the
top of that I look at things like
environmental threats that did not go
away during the pandemic we continue to
try and manage our way and better
understand the responses to things like
increased excess cases of cancer in
Southern New Hampshire so those are
continuing to focus our time yes sir
okay so now I understand it it you're
you're saying that your Workforce issues
are enormously impactful I am but
nevertheless the adverse trending and
long-term impacts of the pandemic are
even yet more significant so they they
are related to some degree as we have
more work to do we also are facing this
Workforce challenge that everybody is
facing so so I'm just trying to
understand because I understand the
workforce issue that's enormous it is
enormous but but like if you could reach
in and pull out of the guts of of the
bigger bar what what do you see as the
long-term impacts that are even more
consequential in terms of health out
Health outcomes public health challenges
how is it that are we we are true our
health conditions are trending so
negatively where we have specific
long-term impacts of the pandemic
such that that's an even bigger problem
than the workforce so I
went hand in hand so the the
trending that's going to be be something
that we also don't know enough about
right now that's the whole point like
the trends are gonna go that are going
in a different direction we're going to
have to figure out along the way what's
going to change our change our priority
and change the focus of what we do and
some of that is yet to we're going to
have to figure that out when that comes
when we see those impacts there's also
things like long covet we don't know
what long covet's going to mean for
people we don't know if there will be
additional resources and then the other
piece is just demographic as we've seen
you know our our population is older as
we all know and as that baby boomer
population gets older we don't know how
we are going to have you know how to
respond to what will be the problems of
the future what I when I look into my
crystal ball I certainly understand that
with a lack of preventative Services
cancer screening is probably the best if
you don't catch those cancers early it
leads to worse outcomes I mean that's a
pretty simple direct line the workforce
is side by side with that and we have
the same challenges that everybody else
has um you know we are not special in
that way the only thing that makes us
you know just have a different focus on
it is the types of people we need to do
the work in public health we have
um you know almost 50 percent of our
staff have advanced or not just
bachelor's degree but have advanced
degrees we have almost 20 percent of our
staff have phds and these are folks that
can go out into the world and make a lot
more money than working for for public
health right now they do it because the
work is important that's the that's the
thing we give to people is an incredible
sense of mission an incredible sense of
accomplishment and importance of their
work but the end of the day people have
to pay their mortgage and and they're
going to have to make those choices and
not only is it an impact for the
workforce of the division of Public
Health Services we have equally seen
that as Workforce issues in the
community so when we have you know we
have been inundated with some covid
money to do some interesting things out
in the community we could come up with
great ideas we may have even had great
ideas before the pandemic we say Okay
Community partner here's the time to do
this great job this great work that
you've always wanted to do and they say
I'd love to do that but I don't have any
staff and so that's the downstream
effect of some of this is that our
health care providers don't have staff
our community service providers don't
have staff and so even if we have great
ideas and the cash today to do it
um that's been a concerning Factor as we
move forward
so I think that you know again for this
slide those are our big issues we've got
we've got some health problems in the
future that we don't really know about
we've got some Workforce and we're going
to ongo we're going to continue to have
to figure out
um how do we plan representative
Stringham uh thanks since you brought up
long-term covered and as part of the uh
in the category of adverse trending of
health conditions uh how many people do
we have with long-term coven uh and uh
what's the mix of how severe they are
and um and what are the resources
um that are worth trying to address that
to understand that issue or address that
issue the short answer is we don't know
we don't have a way in which to count
that and get that data in a way that's
meaningful right now there's no
um standard way to code that it would
take us a while to get that data even if
we did we typically when we look at
health health outcomes we usually have
some standard data sources whether
that's something like our behavioral
risk factor survey which is a random
survey that people say yep I've got
heart disease and I've got asthma you
know and that's how we Trend those
things we also use Hospital data again
to try to try and Trend some of those
health conditions but typically there
are ICD-9 ICD-10 codes that we can count
on to do that all of this is new for us
so we don't know if someone's having
long-term neurological symptoms is that
because of long covet or is it not I
anticipate this is a place over the next
two years where we're going to refine as
a country how do we count that data so
that we can understand how to approach
it and then work with our clinical
partners to understand what are the
interventions that need to be put in
place again it's sort of this fuzzy
thing that we know is out there but I
can't give you a hard number on it
I'm representative
So when you say you know it's this fuzzy
thing that's kind of out there how do
you know is out there certainly from the
art
information from our clinical Partners
In the state we also there are also some
smaller studies the CDC and others and
um have been working hard at trying to
get some of that data in very prescribed
ways working with specific Hospital
Systems across the the country to really
dig down and do the sort of out data
abstracting that you would need to do
going into the depths of those emrs to
pull that information out we're not
ready as a country yet to have a you
know to go Prime Time with a methodology
to be able to get all of that data to
have a a broad picture that is
representative of everyone but we've
certainly seen through certain studies
of certain health systems that it's
there
you provide those studies please excuse
me can you provide those studies please
we will do that thank you
representative hole thank you follow up
on representative herff's question is it
possible to work with one of the major
hospitals or their groups to try and get
a statistical sampling for long covid
and I say that because I hear a lot
about it through personal networks but
there's nothing I can point to in New
Hampshire that says this is
one in five one in ten whatever the
number is I don't have a reference for
for how
um severe the the
total is I am concerned that we haven't
done much to address right there are
whether it's cognitive whether it's
um respiratory there's a number of side
effects
um Beyond just kind of aches and feeling
groggy yes thank you so that that's a
great idea I don't you know this is a
place it's the budget meeting it's
fiscal meeting I don't have a particular
pot of money to do that work I'll just
be honest
um that doesn't mean that we can't work
and engage with our partners to help
understand that
um you know I I think we're going to
look to some of these studies I know
that there's something called an mmwr
which is the cdc's weekly reports that
are of like Health reports that's where
we've seen some of those other long-term
covid studies it's called the more more
mortality and morbidity weekly report
mmwr
um and so that's certainly a
conversation that we can continue to
have with folks like Dr Chan and others
who are working with our clinical
providers to get a finer point on how do
we count in New Hampshire but I and I'm
sure you can appreciate the methodology
of counting we want to do that correctly
great
okay
thank you
all right
um so it's slide nine um this is just an
added fun slide
um I asked my staff the other day so
what you saw previously in slide eight
that's sort of our leadership and our
staff sort of saying these are the
things that we know
um are going to be challenges moving
forward forward I asked my staff the
other day at a staff meeting I said so
what are the three things getting in
your way of getting your job done
um and so you know there's it's
Workforce it's money it's um you know
training all of those things one of the
experiences that we've had through covid
is that while we have been blessed with
large pots of money in some areas that
money is not flexible and it cannot be
spread widely you know we get money for
immunization we get money to do a
certain thing here we have pockets of
the division that have gotten no extra
money and in fact have gotten cut over
time so while you know our overall
budget has increased and we're thankful
for that it is unequal across all areas
and I think that this reflects that as
well our staff's feeling you know I
think the other pieces that they feel as
well like everyone they are coming out
of feeling burnt out
um you know many of my staff as I've
often you know reminded folks we're
working for years at you know 24 7 Pace
we had two two shifts of laboratory
working we were just working non-stop
and I think sort of like the long-term
effects of the pandemic it's only now
that folks are starting to take a breath
and to feel they've been working on
adrenaline for so long and that has
impact over years
um and so we're feeling that we've seen
folks retire I think mostly because they
were age-appropriate to retire and that
was our age four you know Workforce and
we've seen some moving around the thing
that we have that's supportive however
is this incredible purpose to the work
and that is what has kept people engaged
so so you I I think there's a theme in
here
that you have more accounts than most
departments you get these targeted stove
pipe programs that come come at you from
the federal government
it's causing issues in your Workforce
the the there's not the flexibility so
so isn't there a way to go back to the
feds and try to get some waivers and get
some relief so that all this money that
they're putting in uh has some
flexibility
thank you I I yes
um we don't have waiver Authority in the
way that CMS does CDC it you have to
sort of the logic model that goes all
the way back Congress starts with their
Appropriations so you know they say you
will CDC you're going to spend this much
money on cancer and you're going to
spend this much money on this and then
CDC operationalizes what they get from
the federal government and they have
heard from All State Health officials
including myself like please stop with
the massively stove piped funding or to
allow us some flexibility the good news
is we have a couple of funding sources
from them that have allowed us to do
that that's been a little bit more
flexible to focus on Workforce to work
on public health infrastructure in
general so we're we know that they have
heard us that way it hasn't fixed the
problem but they have certainly heard
not only New Hampshire but most States
at this point
thank you so on slide 10 you'll see what
I think is sort of the the big takeaways
from today that are not programmatic but
this is our budget so we've got 124
million total budget again that's not
the coveted money we talked about the
covid money before
um this is our regular old budget about
124 million only about 15 of it is
General funds there's not a lot of
wiggle room there
um when you're talking about what can be
moved around in a flexible way
representative hole thank you
um so that 124 where does that show up
in the budget book I I believe that
number is most likely from the agency
phase so if you turn to page 1014 thank
you the governor's recommended 24 it's
130 million then uh State fiscal year 25
it's 130 million as well
um what you're going to see there is the
primarily the increase from the public
health infrastructure grant that Trisha
was just referring to it's about it's
about five million dollars and that was
added during the governor's phase so so
that's the that's the one discrepancy
there thank you thank you Nathan of
course that's good that we have someone
who does the math we have we have more
representative Waller
thank you I just was wondering about the
15 of General funds are most of those
used for matching
many of them are used for matching and
then a handful you know some of them are
also used for things like food
protection you know stuff where we don't
have federal funds to support that food
protection is a mix of fees and then the
rest is General funds because in statute
we're only allowed to keep three hundred
thousand dollars of our fees like our
licensure fees and then everything else
for the program has to be funded through
general fund
um we have a breadth of our we got more
representative
thank you
since the word matching came up I know
this is not specific to you but it's a
question I've hadn't I'm hoping that you
can answer it with regard to the 3.1
percent across the board uh rate
increase
is that
a generally matched like 50 50 in those
compartments where it's 50 50 and
whatever the match may be in other
places
sure so so the the 3.1 percent that we
were talking about yesterday that that's
that's Medicaid and and you won't you
won't really see that show up in in the
public health budget here today
I understand that but do you understand
my question
that is that federally matched when we
do that increase yes so so what um what
what you see like in the in the Surplus
document
um with the hp2 provision for the 17
million dollars of General funds there
will be a a match of of federal dollars
um now it primarily like if we're
thinking standard Medicaid that's 50 50
um if it's Chip it's 65.35 so there are
some nuances there but yes primarily 50
50. okay thank you
all right
representative hold thank you chairman
so um on page one 1014 thank you Nathan
um so is this a mandated
um 15 85 sharing by federal government
or what drives that 15 percent
so there there's a variety of factors
but
um we we cost allocate many of our
positions and um if if position is cost
allocated you know there there we need
to be able to attribute a specific cost
of the federal portion to the activity
that that individual is doing and
oftentimes you know an individual could
be working on a variety of different
federal grants but then there's a
portion of their work that that would
not qualify
um for for that for that cost allocation
so this isn't this is not necessarily a
statutory match this is just where it is
right
with with so Public Health receives
hundreds of of federal grants and with
every Federal grant there are specific
requirements
um so there may be maintenance of effort
requirements within each one of those
grants so that we would have to put
forward a certain amount of General
funds towards that particular grant us
many are a hundred percent but some are
not it just depends upon the grant I
think yes yeah I would just underscore
that it really is Grant by Grant Federal
Source by federal Source account by
account of where you'll see
um to represent walner also spoken this
there are going to be places where you
see you know I don't know if a lot of
General funds but more General funds
lots of places you'll see Zero and and
that's part of the reason that we have
so many accounts here so that we can
account for each one of those funding
sources separately to try to make it
clear transparent and much easier to
manage yes yes there is there is method
to that Madness of all of the accounts
especially with the federal grants that
come and go we have some grants you'll
hear we're going to talk about the
maternal and child health block grant we
we have had maternal and Child Health
Grants since Federal uh since President
Roosevelt
um you know that's a long time that's a
pretty stable set of money
um and then we have other grants that
change every three years and so managing
that is just uh part of the
administrative work of Public Health
I want to do a time check we've got like
45 minutes in and we've gone through
just under 10 a fourth of your slides so
I know we're you're stopping for
questions uh that's on us but do you do
you imagine the the pace to naturally be
faster than this uh in the next slides I
I would assume that the pace is going to
pick up um but it will be dependent on
the questions that you have right all
right okay
just refer them to the page numbers
great so
um and finally just the last thing I
want to point out on that slide 10 is
really
um that the budget does two big things
it maintains our core infrastructure
things that we just have to do it is in
statute I think I shared the last time
we met a little booklet of all of our
statutory responsibilities so we do that
you know we're always going to have to
inspect milk we're always going to have
to check for rabies and then it also
includes a lot of these Federal
priorities that sort of come and go at
Scopes that expand and contract so
that's the part of the budget that again
is sort of the magic of Public Health
um and then the other thing if you're
trying to match up Staffing we use a mix
of temporary and permanent FTE so many
especially uh over the past I would say
the past four years or so or the past
two bienniums we have moved more to
using 8T and 9 90 positions which are
State temporary positions these aren't
you know contracted these are State
positions but they are associated with a
particular Grant but it's not a it's not
considered a permanent FTE so sometimes
you'll hear me say you know over the
course you've heard me say I've got
almost 400 staff but it only looks like
250. it's because of the the temporary
staff and the way that we count staff in
the state budget is that fair all right
so let's move into 11 this is where the
pace begins to pick up this is our first
set of budgets it's the office of the
director that's me and just a handful of
other people but it's also where we
administer the rent and the
administrative work of the division it's
cost allocated from Grants and generally
funded staff and it's on page 939 of the
governor's recommended budget uh thank
you is this in which of your bubbles uh
do you have the communications role the
one that helps draft any public health
notices does that in your group or no we
currently and I'll get to that currently
we do that with um a lot of our
emergency Public Health Emergency
dollars that is where what funds are Pio
or press information officer that works
under Jake Leon but famously we have
this new Public Health infrastructure
grant that creates a new Communications
person that's going to sit in the office
of the director
and that's going to be a higher level
strategic position to help us with
Communications so you know again I've
got a staff of hundreds of phds and um
super smart people sometimes they like
to talk to each other or at a certain
level and I we've recognized that we
need to do a better job of communicating
with the public and communicating with
our with our policy makers
great so um we can jump into our first
Bureau which is on slide 12. this is
informatics and health statistics it has
a number of smaller grants some of our
surveys things like behavioral risk
factor survey it has our we have moved
our cancer registry back into this
particular group it had been in our
cancer program we think it fits better
in with a lot of the other data
so because there's not a lot of money
for technology in here relative to the
amount of informatics work that could be
done in your area I assume that most of
the money to to support the informatics
function is over in Mr weeder's budget
somewhere
yes that's correct okay so there there
are ten positions in here of of these
ten
um could you give us a sense of what
their skill sets are then are they
informaticists are they data entry
people are they you know what are who
are these 10 people sure so it's it's a
mix um there's again just a handful of
them we have informaticists in there so
folks that are really working looking at
the software and the hardware and making
the data flow from one place to another
we also have a set of Health
statisticians that are making sure that
um our analyzes are correct we also have
a number of these folks work on our DHHS
data portal so again matching those two
things making sure the analysis is
correct making sure the informatics is
correct so that it looks pretty in
Tableau when you open up your website so
one of the themes I've been asking about
this cycle is the extent to which we
have a mature data warehouse strategy
and that we have the right tools that
are used commonly to do the uh sort of
the the front end queries into the
system uh do you do you do you know your
technology well enough in this area to
know if you're leveraging a common
platforming system or if you're doing
your own thing here no we are certainly
using the ebi the Enterprise business
yeah until whatever I intelligence I
always forget the eye but yes the ebi is
at the core of what of men much of what
we do we also have a system of Legacy
programs however uh that are
programmatic in
um and may have to do with all of those
stove types of funding so a lead program
and you know cancer registry is a great
example it that doesn't particularly use
the ebi because it is sort of stood up
you know in a separate system so but the
degree to which we can leverage that
back end is where we've been going is
our chief of health statistics and
informatics she probably spends half of
every day with Dave Wieters in some
capacity to ensure that as a department
we're working together yeah I know her
through the vital records function so
they're representative
thank you chairman
sorry I'm just catching up I'm on page
940 still
um looking at lines 28
and then indirect costs from the last
biennium going forward roughly there was
eight billion sorry eight million
dollars spent in the department of which
2 million was in direct cost that two
million goes away leaving us about six
yet this year's operating cost is almost
seven and it predominantly shows up in
transfers to plant and property almost a
million dollars more sure so I'll answer
the easy one first so the indirect cost
line um that was centralized to account
9 500 uh within the office of the
commissioner the transfers to plant and
property so the department of
administrative Services charges us rent
for the property at Hazen drive and they
determine a square footage rate and they
provide us that figure and then we pay
them and we don't really have too much
negotiating room there so that's a
that's roughly a 25 increase is that
going to be across all right so
so
um the facilities that will be coming
here I believe next Maybe
next Friday to present um we're going to
be talking about the other half that
that Das charges us as well that shows
up in the facilities budget but this
here this is limited to Hazen drive so
just Hazen Drive does it also include
our space in brown and the warehouse
just Hazen Drive
when you come next time maybe you're not
prepared today right because
drilling down at this level can you get
dollars per square foot that's just
right what is what is the facility what
is the total square footage of haze and
drive and what are we paying per square
foot for that a 25 increase seems
significant I I would agree and I can
absolutely do that
I think there's a phrase that says the
rent is too darn High
okay representative Stringham for a
question uh just follow up on that did I
also hear you uh say that um that the
administrative
um uh 5110 account is then allocated to
specific grants so uh if you're um the
rent you're paying is higher you have
more
um
costs that can be allocated to specific
grants which may be uh reimbursed under
those federal federal grants is that
accurate
I would I would have to follow up on on
that question uh I
is there an easy answer yes yes we would
be able to
follow up uh yeah yes we would be able
to better leverage federal dollars to
address that the only thing I would add
is our federal dollars are pretty static
so again we use those funds what it
means you know as those allocated costs
increase even things like salaries
increase or rent increases it just means
that we have fewer dollars to actually
put out into Community to do the work so
you know that and what we'll see as you
go through these we have many federal
grants that are you know less than two
hundred thousand dollars a year and then
we have some that are bigger that are
several million but especially on those
tiny grants on the you know grants that
are less than 200 000
um all of the allocated costs really
start squeezing in into it and don't
allow us to do necessarily the work that
is intended to be done
thank you representative oh all set
representative norgren per question
thank you very much sorry to be late
crash on 89.
um
40 indirect costs that's zeroed out for
24 and 25 cute yes so the indirect costs
were centralized within account 9 500
within the office of the commissioner so
so we move those expenses to one Central
account from multiple areas in one place
yes
thank you very much
great Nathan where is that which page do
you know that that went to
it's on page 1069 of the governor's
recommended budget
excellent please continue Ms Kelly thank
you so much so on slide 13 this is just
another one of these Graphics that we
shared with you the last time I was with
you to talk about sort of data
modernization and public health
infrastructure and this just underscores
that we've been able to use some of our
covid funding again coveted funding
doesn't show up in here but we've been
able to use coveted funding and other
funds to really start thinking about
public health infrastructure in here
you'll also see
um at the end in the governor's phase we
added this grant that's called the
public health infrastructure Grant it is
new it has not come to fiscal yet so we
don't have the full details it's been
awarded to us we're still negotiating
the budget line items with CDC but
fiscal will see that and will be able to
provide some more detail but I can tell
you at a very high end that public
health infrastructure and data
modernization Grant is going to help us
with things like cancer epidemiology
that's an area where we just haven't you
know our cancer program keeps sort of
getting smaller and smaller and our
needs for understanding cancer incidents
is growing so we're being able to use
the infrastructure grant to get the kind
of epidemiology support that we need to
be able to do future work
um and you know so the other piece too
on slide 14 is just a screenshot not
from our covid website it looks like our
covid website but it's not this is
actually our opioid dashboard that we
have on our DHHS data system and this is
a place where we've leveraged funds from
something called opioid data to action
grant that sits in another Bureau but a
chunk of the money comes and sits over
is utilized by informatics in order to
create this Tableau Data dashboard
that's available online as well as to
help support things like our
prescription drug monitoring program to
have the data support that they need to
be able to present the data to look at
prescription opioid prescription data
over time so it's just an example of the
way we we sort of take all the uh those
stove types and try to blend them to the
best of our ability we don't rigidly
stay within each lane but we it we're
not always able to be as flexible as we
want to but when we can we try and braid
them across areas
so on slide 15 we jump into the Health
Access equity and policy Bureau again
relatively small Bureau relatively small
numbers of of Grants
um we uh as I noted this is where some
of our sometimes we affectionately call
this The Island of Misfit Toys we have
things like our prescription drug
monitoring program our cannabis program
as well as our rural health and Primary
Care programs and I'm happy to answer
any questions about those
all right representative Mooney
thank you if you don't mind I'd like to
go to the cancer registry just a bit I
see that was on your previous slides
there is a bill forthcoming related to
Merrimack House Bill 614 that's right
and the question is is that money in
that bill
contained in the budget we're looking at
no it is not but it would be support it
would enable us to do um so 6 14 is a
bill that would like us to take a look
at a feasibility study to understand
whether or not we need to open up an
entire case you know do some real
in-depth case uh understanding of what's
going on in the excess cases of kidney
cancer in Merrimack so the funding
that's here is simply to maintain the
cancer registry and to have a little bit
of you know the we we contract with
Dartmouth the support that it takes just
to do the cancer registry
um and so the 614 would be additive to
that but it would use the data of the
cancer registry
okay uh thank you next question is with
regards to that cancer registry how many
communities benefit from that particular
section of the budget would you say
every community in the state of New
Hampshire people with cancer it
represents the data for our people all
people with cancer in the state thank
you
representative Holt sorry chairman we're
probably destroying your timeline
um on page 15 therapeutic cannabis
program
but as we start collection collecting
this data what happens to the list of
individuals that participate in that
program what um so thank you so that is
uh confidential data so we keep it it is
separate unlike
um we were talking about the ebi before
where we try and use data across systems
the therapeutic cannabis program is
completely separate in part because it
is still federally illegal and so that
is kept in its own separate box okay so
that data isn't shared with any other
departments internal even within the
state yeah thank you I I would also
assume that they have privacy procedures
in place before things go into the data
warehouse It's been scrubbed of correct
Phi correct so they're looking at
anonymized data right the but the
background data there is still Phi in
the background usually you know in order
to make some of those connections but
for cannabis cannabis is in its own
system separate we have its own data
system it's again one of the challenges
we have in public health because we
sometimes have these one-off systems in
this case for a very good legal reason
oh no understand that's why I'm asking
these questions so it is truly separate
yes not not just another
folder per se within another system
right no and you know I mean we go as
far as to even our paper records are
under lock and key we have something
called the cage where we put paper
records where it's completely separate
and you cannot you know others cannot
get access to it even for paper records
and certainly not for the Cannabis
program we have over 13 000 people that
are currently in the candidate
registered in the Cannabis program
so so to talk about the time allocation
here one this shows tremendous fortitude
on your part to be able to keep going
but
um I I was thinking that if we could
basically do this in a total of three
hours that we might work through lunch
and just let people go before the snow
got worse that was a possibility but I'm
starting to feel to me like we're going
to need to take a lunch break at some
point and come back
so that was to your point yesterday
representative tolersky I'm I actually
remembered
so
and and I I I'm gonna have
a bunch of questions on these little
programs yes sir
do you think we could with two hours
remaining get to does anybody strongly
object to trying to close finish by one
that gets us an extra hour right
well that was a proposal but we're the
ones that keep asking questions I get it
I'll try and be conscious of that but
and I'm about to ask a bunch so so I'm
I'm as bad as I'm probably the worst so
so I'm just going to tell you what my
questions are and and just simple little
answers if you can
the hospital flux program I've forgotten
some of the details of it other than I
recall that this was a pretty cool
program correct so if you could just
remind us of what that is I also
um on the therapeutic cannabis program
the last this is my fourth term I keep
asking the same question
are are we at risk because of the
competition from recreational pot of
having our therapeutic cannabis program
you know cave in because the
alternatives are out there and cheaper
I'm worried about the the long-term
sustainability of that program and then
on the prescription drug monitoring I'm
curious what they do relative to the
prescription drug affordability board so
those are my three questions I'll try
and answer those sort of in backward
order of the prescription drug
monitoring program is not connected to
the prescription affordability program
those are two separate things
prescription drug monitoring really is
focused on opioids and stimulants and
just monitoring how the how prescribers
and providers tap into that data to see
what other prescriptions an individual
has totally separate
um the question around therapeutic
cannabis
um around whether
um recreational pot is or recreational
Cannabis is impacting that certainly we
believe so so our alternative treatment
centers which are the retail
environments that do the growing
production selling
um they will tell you that they are
certainly feeling a hit
um because their product is more
expensive a than the gray market and B
what you can get in Massachusetts they
will also tell you and we will tell you
too it's probably of higher quality
because of the testing Pro the testing
that we have on it and the nature that
it is for medicinal use and so there's a
great deal of Education that goes with
it so you would miss out you know I I
envisioned this if you were a you know
older than 65 years old and had cancer
whether or not you would want to go into
a recreational shop somewhere in Lowell
or you would rather go into an ATC in
New Hampshire that's focused on how do
we per how do they provide
um the sort of products that could help
someone who is going through
chemotherapy I think in general folks
that are going through some of those
health conditions appreciate the
alternative treatment centers we have
here the fact is it's expensive and
nothing and it's all cash
um so you know insurance doesn't pay for
it or anything so regardless flower
which is the you know the vegetative
Port whether you smoke it or somehow or
the products the Edibles The Vapor
cartridges those things are all
expensive so yes they feel the impact of
that market outside the flex program it
so I've encouraged them to I forget the
gentleman's name that has been running
that for a while but I I've been
encouraging them now for three or four
terms to keep coming back to the
legislature with proposals so that they
can continue to be competitive that's a
program that I think we want to sustain
regardless of what we do with
recreational pot I I appreciate that and
I think we've made some subtle change
we've made incremental changes over the
past couple years to help them along the
way things like visiting patients we're
now going to allow for visiting patients
from out of state to come and use those
resources we've made some internal
changes again but there hasn't been any
sort of we can't address the big gorilla
which is the recreational Market that
exists all around us right and then
Hospital flux and Hospital Flex program
this is where we it's 100 federal funds
and we work with our partners to do
um to support those little hospitals for
the most part to do things like Medicare
boot camp where we pay for training so
that those little hospitals can maximize
revenues those are the piece the
hospital we work with the hospitals and
with the hospital Association in order
to ensure that they have the sort of
technical support that they need so that
they can keep their doors open
representative
thank you
I'll be in the running for the number of
questions I guess on the prescription
monitoring I recall correctly we were
um administer sorry we were
um the prescriptions per person for
opioids was something absurd like a
hundred tablets per person in the state
or something this goes back a couple
years are we still seeing that higher
level of
um has that dropped off so those numbers
have gone down I'm pulling out some data
here
um you know I have my trusty computer
um we have seen
um that the numbers have gone down of
actually pills prescribed which is great
um we've also in this in the same scene
the utilization from the providers and
the pharmacists go up that's exactly the
crisscross that we want to see that the
utilization of the data is is up the
number of prescriptions are going down
to probably what's appropriate the thing
that we are most concerned about not
only in New Hampshire but across the
country is the stimulants on the other
hand are starting to creep back up are
going up while as opioids are going down
okay and then separate question if HB
639 passes right and I believe it's gone
through the house at this point right
Senate is undecided where that goes but
if it does go forward what happens to
the therapeutic cannabis program as a
whole does it become necessary right is
it now completely redundant yeah that's
that's a really interesting question so
my my recommendation would be that it
doesn't become redundant that there's
always a program there is value for
having a program that's carved out for
therapeutic needs
um for a couple of reasons one around
taxing it or any additional fees that
you keep it more affordable than you
would with the recreational product as
well as that we keep the sort of limits
around things like testing to make sure
that those products are really safe
super safe and that we are administering
but mainly for an affordability of the
program for the participants we would
want to keep that separate there are a
couple of different options on the table
either that stays within DHHS there's
been some thought that it could move if
there was some sort of liquor plus
cannabis commission you know there's
been some thought you throw it over
there to administer I think there are
pros and cons with that right and I
understand we're a budget
driven group as opposed to a policy I'm
just asking because what do we do with
the positions and
we have um you know historically we we
put Public Health put that program back
together it was a little bit like Humpty
Dumpty when it first started it had the
um it was broken out into different
sections across the department several
bienniums ago we actually moved it all
to Public Health to make it coherent to
make sure it focused on meeting access
to Services which is really what our job
is and to keep an eye on the Laboratory
Testing of it so is there any way to
right now I believe it's cash as you
mentioned earlier is there any way to
tie it back to insurance or not without
risking disclosure of the individuals
that are on there
um I think it's a I think while it is
still a federally scheduled the
insurance piece is off the table
okay all right
um 17 just again because I made all
these slides I'm going to make you look
at them
um
slide 17 is another piece that sits
within that Bureau of something called
our Health Professions data center this
is a project again under the radar we
don't talk about it very much but we've
worked with all of oplc with all of the
medical boards or health related boards
and we get information about providers
and this is just an example of that data
where we look at the behavior health
professionals in the state
um almost you know 42 percent are over
60 years old of psychiatrists in the
state and if you look down at that
bottom roll we can see that anticipated
reduction in capacity over the next five
years is is alarming we're certainly
losing over a quarter of our staff
moving forward and we use this data to
support things like our slurp program my
favorite acronym in all of Public Health
State loan repayment program to really
focus on what professionals do we need
to attract and retain in the state of
New Hampshire
um so that we have Equitable access
address state
on so this data is counter-intuitive to
me you've got older people in psychiatry
than you do in psychology
um as a percentage but we're expecting
to have a higher reduction in capacity
of of the younger population a
psychologists in the older population of
psychiatrists yeah I think it has
something to do with also the numbers in
there
um you know it is counterintuitive but
it gives you that we have fewer
psychiatrists to begin with again those
are medical professionals with um
Advanced Training than even say your
psychologists certainly more advanced
training than your than your nurse NPS
your psych NPS so obviously that data
drives a lot of our concern about our
Workforce issues yes yes
the the data that we're working looking
for we will have a report on the data
professions data and the ruralhealth at
DH at HHS oversight in March so that's a
preview for more to come
um psychic I did thank you it's like NPS
what's the NP stand nurse practitioner
McQ
um slide 18 we're going to move into our
Bureau of Public Health protection wave
this is only our third of eight bureaus
I'm trying to go fast
um a significant amount of our
regulatory programs sit within the
Bureau of population of Public Health
protection
um in in this is included our food
protection radiological Health lead
poisoning per lead poisoning prevention
um you will see that in this particular
bureau there's a lot of fees so things
like radiological health is supported by
the fees that we gather to go inspect
things like mammography machines those
things are fairly self-funded as I noted
earlier with food protection by Statute
we're only allowed to keep three hundred
thousand dollars of the fees that we
generate the rest have to be funded by
the general fund
um lead poisoning supported by both
General funds and federal funds as a
result of a lot of interest over the
past bienniums in reducing lead
poisoning among our kiddos
so we can take any questions in any of
those areas if you'd like or not I can
go to slide I have a question on line
20.
um
I you know I know that to some extent
we're taking Federal money and we're
creating a mobile service to do
coronavirus injections
um and I'm just curious if maybe that
would be an opportunity to leverage some
of that Federal money to help us improve
accessibility to lead poisoning testing
in kids
that is a very interesting idea that I'd
have to think more about okay okay
thank you
representative hole thank you so
um would you like a gavel down there
would that help absolutely not
um bottom of page 18 right 12 positions
um and
oh thank you
um and it looks like this continues over
to the bottom of page 959 right we're
spending 2.2 million dollars on per year
on lead prevention and testing
um how much of that is kits and how much
of that is just overhead and
administering and
foreign
in the governor's Budget on page 958 at
the bottom
um you'll see in state fiscally you're
24 and and just to note the increase in
in personnel there we uh we actually
moved a position from 7936 into this so
you will see 800 000 there you'll see
with Benefits it's about 1.2 million
dollars in Personnel related costs
um we we do have a a contract line but
Trisha I don't know if you want to speak
to to the delivery of services and what
those Personnel are providing sure so um
in our program we have a number of
things that that pays for so primarily
it pays for nurse case management we
have some CD some federal funds we also
use some general funds one of the things
that you may recall is over time we have
lowered something that's called The
Action level for when we take action
when we support families that comes in
two ways one there's nurse case
management that comes with that with
that lower level and then on the other
side is the Environmental side where we
go out and and test especially in rental
homes the other piece that we have used
some of the additional General funds is
to support individuals both landlords
and primary homeowners so that they can
have access to resources to remediate
when lead is found in their house and so
that is balanced with some funds that
are in HUD to be able to provide some
loans and to provide some grants for
remediation so it's a mix of a lot of
different things in that line so we have
nurse case management we have basic
education one of the things I handed out
to you if you want to move I have five
of these you can fight over them
um we have new baby board books that one
of our
um one of our staff actually wrote and
this is sort of a national thing right
now about healthy free lead free me
happy happy healthy lead free me
um and we give these out and all the
pediatrician offices so if you have a
baby in your life or someone who has a
baby make sure that they have that and
it's one of the ways that we try to
communicate around the importance of
lead screening it was nice that somebody
wrote it so that we could understand it
time next but I think we're short on
time so great I'm just struggling with
right the contracted program Services go
down by north of six hundred thousand
dollars
in the biennium yet the department goes
up by 400 so there's a net million
dollar difference between
right in Lines 102 in total between last
budget and this budget
um wait a minute okay
gotta okay right so
so if if you look at class 102
many of those funds are being shifted up
to class 74. the reason for that is we
are required to identify
whether any any award that we provide
that's federal dollars is a
sub-recipient which would be reflected
in class 74 or a contractor as divided
by two CFR 200 through 331 and and
you'll see throughout these accounts
you'll see a number of those movements
where we're shifting funds from 102 to
74 where originally we thought they were
a contractor the easiest way to think
about a contractor under the federal
definition is they're providing Services
either directly to the department or we
have primary control over those
activities a sub-recipient is typically
where an organization a contracted
organization is providing services on
behalf of the department they're in
charge of more the programmatic details
they may be conducting eligibility
determinations as well essentially they
have more control over the program and
they're providing those Direct exactly
to clients or individuals
so I'm just trying to figure out right
as we go through right equipment new
replacement goes up almost doubles
between the last biennium and this
biennium the the costs are 10 plus
actually closer to 15 round numbers
between last biennium in this biennium
for total budget so just where
so so you're you're asking okay what are
the increases so one of the increases
are is the the movement of that one
position from 79.36 you'll also see an
increase in class 50
um where where the governor's
recommended budget has included funding
for additional temporary positions as
well that also has a net impact on the
benefits line
um the let me see here's some quick back
of the envelope Map There's I mean
there's a slight increase in out of
state travel
um and some other slight increases but
those those Personnel lines are the the
key drivers the movement and the and the
additional dollars for temporary
positions and if I can add those people
are because we've lowered that Action
level and quite frankly we were
um
uh I I never want to say I'm thankful
for the pandemic but those lower
screening we were we were certainly
prepared that we were going to have a
much greater increase in kids that had
elevated lead screens that we needed to
do something about but um that lowering
came right at the pandemic when we also
had a dip in the number of kids who were
screened so we've sort of slow rolled
into this but as more kids get screened
we're going to have increased work
so I can move on to slide 20 again just
some visual fewer kids have been being
screened we anticipate that that's going
to go up these numbers you almost got
the 20. uh on 19. oh
there well I'm just I'm just curious
because I'm looking at page 960 on the
budget book and and
um this is where you begin to talk about
eph tracking yes also on this page is
climate change adaptation where there
was money in the current budget that
looks like it's all zeroed out yes
where's that money now sure so um
environmental Public Health tracking
it's a horrible name if you're worried
about people tracking you but it's
really just looking at environmental
Public Health Data
um so I just want to be clear about that
the climate adapt climate change
adaptation was a Federal grant that we
had received and this current biennium
we no longer will receive that Grant in
the upcoming biennium
good we we solved the problem that's
great
we've solved it was just meant to be a
joke go ahead
nothing else I need to add to that thank
you
um so again slide 20 just the data
around lead fewer screens we need to get
those screening numbers back up as we
get those screening numbers up we're
going to need those people to take care
of the kiddos that's just one of the the
takeaways from the past two years
Mr chair
thank you so just remind me where did we
move what are the new values for lead
screening I I was out for four years I
didn't keep track sure so I think if you
look on I've got stuff popping up on
here we have if you if you really look
in at that data and I'm trying to yeah
what was it and what is the current
value it has moved and I'm going to keep
because I'm going to show my age because
it was at one time ten it moved down to
seven and a half and we are down now at
five and uh is this in micrograms per
liter yes
that's a leader
so we are moving moving down
um and I think you can see that in in
there
um on July 21 and July 1 2021 was
lowered from seven and a half to five
and for children 72 months and younger
so it has gone from 10 down to five over
what period of time
um over more than a decade it was at
seven and a half certainly for a number
of sort of the the mid
2010s it was at seven out of five I
don't remember when we paid that thank
you
all right so um the next slide is around
food protection you've been hearing me
talk a lot about food I love the food
program because it never really gets a
lot of air time it is one of the oldest
things we do in public health when I
showed you this book right here one of
the main things it talks about is food
adulteration and food safety and testing
milk that you know like so for over a
hundred years this has been what we've
been doing
um what we license and inspect over 5
000 establishments we also do things
like with shellfish to make sure when
you're having raw oysters you don't get
sick and die
um and food and beverage manufacturers
one of the things that we would like to
highlight in here is that we actually we
do have a prioritized need in this area
for overtime expenses I think that the
governor's budget uh may have zeroed out
our overtime perhaps inadvertently we
need overtime in this place especially
when we think about inspectors that are
highly trained like our milk inspectors
so would you do me a favor tell me the
page number and the line item and how
much you're you think you need if you
turn to page 954
and it's class 18 it's at the bottom of
page 954. in the agency's original
budget submission we had included ten
thousand dollars of overtime in each
year
um we had also submitted an additional
prioritized need which which was not
funded for fifteen thousand dollars so
so that would have been twenty five
thousand it would have been 25 000 total
um and and the reason that we're asking
for that is because on an annual basis
we have exceeded our ten thousand
dollars on a pretty regular basis by by
a significant amount and it's always
required transferred so we're requesting
this amount to reflect what is closer to
the actual cost that we incur each year
so any amount here would also be subject
to the 10 percent pay raise and would
also be subject to additional benefits
yes so so even if it was ten thousand
dollars it's probably more like nineteen
thousand
we are we need at a minimum twenty five
thousand dollars in here you know I and
just to give you color behind that we
have two major milk inspectors which is
why I keep talking about it one of them
is on an extended medical leave we have
one milk inspector to make sure that all
milk that is sold outside
um it needs to be blessed by our staff
before in for at Federal for federal law
before it can do go to interstate
commerce so we have we've been working
someone and we've maxed out their comp
time into and we've aired into like
federal labor standards act problems we
need overtime also representative
norgren
um I I I'm just open to asking Mr Ripple
to keep track of this and this could be
one of our one of our agreed upon
plus-ups if you would agree
yeah and and and because I'm cheap I I
would just throw 20 at it knowing that
it's going to be much more than 20 by
the time you do 10 pay raise and
benefits and
so could we keep track of 20 for that
sure thank you representative hole
um looking at page 955 for this
department right it looks like there's
also a request to go from 14 to 16 is to
additional people are they moving over
from a different department or is this
unveiled positions
sure
here's the conversions yeah so on page
955 you'll see the class 50 the 105
being zeroed out
um those the two temporary positions
that are there are being converted and
that's the increase
thank you of course great
so we can jump to slide 22. oh
um uh just kind of a new newbie question
here is uh
um you know obviously we have a lot of
Staff openings which Drive tends to
drive over time
um to higher numbers
um would we expect the same kind of
overtime numbers if we were fully
staffed uh based on the budget
um
certainly being fully staffed would be
helpful
um this is not an area where we have
massive openings right now what's also
driving this is we have an increased
number of licensees in the community and
it's also seasonal so it's not so if you
think about the summer time where we
have food trucks and Boardwalk
facilities and all sorts of things that
pop up so we tend to accumulate overtime
seasonally and then it pops back down so
I think overtime is sort of always going
to be a
part of the price of doing business in
this work because of some of the the ups
and downs thank you
great so
what opportunities are there for some
level of self-assessments Slash
self-inspection at maintenance instead
of having
um
employees actually go visit these right
having the various dairy farms do
self-inspection self-certification and
then increasing let's say maybe the
penalties for
falsifying data or anything like that so
that we're not doing this that we're
allowing the Farms to manage themselves
so it
forward in this space we are navigating
between federal law and state law so
there are you know again we've talked a
lot about milk there's a lot of federal
law and FDA regulations that we need to
follow that we don't have up but we
don't have choices around so that
requires someone to come in and take a
look at it we've worked very
collaboratively with our restaurant you
know so I think more about something
like restaurants where we may have a
little bit more room we've prioritized
High need or high risk restaurants over
some of the lower risk restaurants as
well which is how we've tried to manage
both time and energy
great so if we go to slide 22
um I think that's about halfway through
we've spoken for a little over an hour
and a half so I might be on par
um and uh this is our Bureau of family
health and nutrition as I noted earlier
this is the place where we've got tons
of small grants and big grants there are
also some things that are policies that
you are sometimes interested in included
in these um in this Bureau as well
um the sparrow has the most accounting
units so we can go through them or you
can just ask questions as you would like
one of the things I will note to you
right off the top on slide 22 the teen
pregnancy prevention program we will not
be funding that in the next biennium
that was put in earlier in the agency
phase but it will be zeroed out going
forward
representative Wallner
thank you I was wondering in the
pregnancy risk monitoring system what
are you what are you monitoring in is is
one of them
um drug use yes so thank you that's a
great question so this is something
called our prams survey pregnancy risk
monitoring something
um and it is a a survey that we send out
to women who have just given birth it's
again like all of our surveys it's
voluntary in nature but people provide
their um information anonymized around
what their experience was while pregnant
and postpartum as well as some of their
health risks which could include
substance use not only opioids which you
know probably has uh people may not be
as forthcoming with something like
opioids but one of the things that we've
been tracking in here is cannabis use
which we find that people are pretty
forthcoming about
um so that's one of probably one of the
best ways we have to generally Trend the
use of something like cannabis during
pregnancy and postpartum
representative Mooney notes that there's
still money in the forecasted budget yes
because we at the time of writing this
we thought we would be getting
additional federal funds for the teen
pregnancy prevention program we are not
applying for those federal funds
so going forward my plan is after we go
through all of all of the presentations
is I provide a series of change requests
to the committee to consider this would
be one of those technical changes
understood thank you of course thank you
um the bottom of page 22 is our maternal
and child health grant that 5190 that
has a lot of things in it but I'll just
draw your attention to it that that is
the you know as I said it's been around
since FDR
um and was modernized under Ronald
Reagan
um and is one of the places that we
actually have flexibility it is a mix of
we have federal funds we also have some
general funds that are maintenance of
effort that are attached to those
um meant much of the general funds that
we use in maternal and child health is
to support our federally qualified
health centers for Primary Care and
prenatal care representative hole thank
you
um not sure whether this is for Mr
Ripple or Mr White right
in terms of these changes because we
haven't seen hb2 update sorry hb1 in
terms of this update as it works through
I guess there's
how do we when do we get the next
version of this with all the requested
changes the 10 percent
foreign
won't be in house bill one it will be in
House Bill two um and you won't see it
split out by department or accounting
unit or anything like that
and I expect House Bill 2 to be ready
for Signature probably tomorrow
great thank you we can move to slide 23
which are more accounting units in
family and health
um and uh in here I'll I'll take note
that one of our other prioritized needs
that was not included in the governor's
um in the governor's budget is in the
5260 account which is the WIC
supplemental nutrition program again a
great program that we don't talk about
enough
um there is some legislation floating
through around WIC Farmers Market this
is where if we were to move forward with
WIC Farmers Market we would ask for
additional General funds to be placed in
there
some history on WIC Farmers Market we
used to have the program in the 1990s
and early 2000s we actually stopped it
at that time because it was incredibly
administratively burdensome in those
years because it used to be that you'd
have to have like a paper coupon and
you'd have to take that paper coupon to
a farmer that accepted it and it just
didn't work well fast forward to today
when our WIC participants have a
essentially what's a debit card and they
can swipe and most of our Farmers have a
little square that they can accept a
swipe we think that it's the time is now
to be able to get some matching funds so
that we can access federal funds for the
um for the Wic Farmers Market
so I want to talk about family planning
um great that's on page 969
and
um so I have a few questions in this
area uh one the
the actual expense of 22 relative to the
adjusted authorization in 23 there's a
substantial jump there could you just
explain that jump
so uh are you are you speaking of the
fact that we expended fewer of our
general funds it goes from 755 to
2.817 million right so part of this as
we all know we had budgeted to fund a
number of Family Planning providers
um at three additional family planning
providers including Planned Parenthood
of Northern New England which was our
largest provider and received a
significant sum of funds from us those
contracts were rejected by the council
and so we did not those we did not
expend those dollars we did expend
dollars on the other four agencies that
we per that have Family Planning
Services those agencies are in places
like amoskege and Lamprey are in
community health centers sure that's
this authorized amount for the current
year
um is that likely to be spent or because
I don't under I don't believe those
contracts were let still yeah we will it
we will likely in 23 not spend all that
money but what we're looking forward to
do in the next biennium is to reallocate
some of those General funds to the
existing providers and also work with
the community to see where else we can
use those funds to ensure that we have
access to reproductive health services
that in a way in which that our Council
finds acceptable
so one of the things we did with hb2 and
I I think there was uh
some money put into hb1 for this was to
incentivize new vendors to step up and
and compete for these contracts and I
don't remember how much that was whether
it was ten thousand dollar spiff for
five figures yeah so
um so I understand that no one actually
qualified to get get that additional
money yes no one qualified or no and no
one there was not no one tried right
that's what I think you're saying
there's no one in tried correct okay so
if we were to double that would that
have an impact on those that may want to
compete for it we are always happy to
put out new proposals at new requests
for proposals to see if there are
additional providers that are interested
in in meeting the services that we have
so doubling the incentive for a new
provider could potentially help
okay so I'm I representative norgren one
of the things I've submitted to Mr
Ripple
is a similar to the hb2 item and Family
Planning that we did last year that that
I think we all had sort of a partisan
difference on was just being able to
have that incentive pay so that new
vendors who hadn't previously received
Family Planning money could would be
incentivized to compete so so what what
I would like to do is is to increase you
know double what we did last year Mr
Ripple and and and then we can discuss
it later you know in a week or two you
guys can tell me why you think I'm wrong
but but that that's one of the things
I'd like us to to discuss
and and then Mr Ripple one one of the
hb2 items that was I think fairly
controversial was related to
I'm going to say it was financial and
physical
separation and I think we got rid of the
physical separation and kept the
financial separation and we put that
limitation in hb2 does that language
live on or do we need to if we wanted it
to continue we would have to add it to
hb2 again
uh I'll have to take a look at
House Bill 2 from two years ago and see
if it was for the biennium only or if it
had a repeal date
um
I don't recall a repeal date
specifically in it but I just don't some
of some of the hp2 stuff is only for the
budget term and then some of it seems to
be more perpetual and I don't know the
distinction I'll look it up now if it
doesn't say for the biennium only and if
it doesn't have a repeal date then it
would live on so some aspects of it were
chapter law and others were RSA
see that you know if I were smarter that
would mean something to me because I've
heard that term you know probably 10
times in the last two years
so did I I you want to turn your mic on
it's not really relevant chapter lock
and live on too
okay did you have a question on this in
this area yes but when you're done I'm
done
um so regarding the federal dollars I
think they're a little off I believe
that I can't this off top my head I
believe the title 10 funding from the
federal is 800k per year but I could be
wrong about that but the difference
between that whatever that is and the
actual FY 24 not the actual but the
budget at fy24 is we were between a two
different terms and so you're able to
roll over so that explains why the fy24
is substantially higher because you're
able to roll a bunch over into that and
add it into the title 10. but I don't
believe the fy25 should also have that
extra money in there
so um I am looking to to my uh to
Shelley back there I think it was
because some of it was rolled over we're
also in we are also expecting increased
federal dollars under this Federal
Administration
that's already been allocated I mean
this Administration yes this so we can
adjust this moving forward and make it
closer to what the actual notice of
award is I I don't have that notice
award number off the top of my head I I
get that I think you're missing my point
I'm not talking specifically about the
award I mean I think it's lower than you
think but that doesn't really matter
but there's a dip but there's definitely
not two point whatever it is million
dollars
okay yeah the awards like 800k I think
or something maybe a little more but
that differential up to the 2 million is
because of what you rolled over from the
previous three year whatever it is
period but that will not should not show
my 25 right that additional correct okay
yeah
so we can work I can work with Nathan
and get that number closer if we want to
have a change number
so so of the general funds for the
coming year of eight thirty seven
thousand and the federal of two points
something is is there a a matching
requirement there or is this all
separate I remember this to be separate
place where um
Clarity from the Federal
go say that
um
federal government in the in the law
says they will not pay for the entirety
of the program that is what it said from
that is what the language says they will
not pay for them yes please thank you so
the the guidance that is available is
include financial support from sources
other than title 10 as no Grant may be
made for an amount equal to 100 of the
Project's estimated costs
there you go that's what the FED spell
is okay so there's a lot of numbers
below 100 though yeah so representative
Waller you had a question here
yes I just
could you I think you've already
explained this to us once before but
could you go again explain the
difference between the grants for public
assistance and contracts
uh absolutely so
um
there's sub-recipient and contractor as
defined by federal uniform guidance
think contractor is an organization that
that we contract with and this is where
it gets confusing because I'm going to
use contract in both terms we contract
with a contractor and they provide those
Services primarily to us they're not
making eligibility determinations it may
be more technical assistance it could be
like like some kind of public
information initiative something along
those lines think many of our I.T
um our RIT contracts versus a
sub-recipient and our sub-recipients are
are those organizations that we contract
with that are providing services on
behalf of the department and so they
have more programmatic control as
defined within the contract but they
could be one of the key drivers within
the federal guidance is are they making
eligibility determinations and so we
have to report on our sub-recipients and
and part of many of the change changes
that you're seeing here is is partly
clean up to make sure that it's easier
for us to track this information going
forward because historically sometimes
when we budget under the contract line
we may or may not know at that point in
time whether we're going to have a
contractor or we're going to have a
sub-recipient and sometimes you really
have to dig into the details to make
that determination and to make those
strategic decisions about how you want
to execute the objectives of that
program and and I'll just highlight so
the way that looks in Family Planning we
certainly have our family planning
providers that's one type of contract
and then we have a contract for our data
system and so that's the other type so
that's that's why you see both yes
I think I got it finally okay thank you
thank you Mr chair
so
I guess Nathan is it possible with all
the changes that we're talking about
because we're moving around potentially
large sums of money if this two million
dollars in 2025 under the federal funds
is is maybe off by more than a million
for you to either Redline this book as
is I don't know if that's an even an
option
can you take hb1 as the governor handed
it to us and make the changes in real
time on top of it so we can just replace
the pages or provide it in some format
that's similar
wasn't saying Mr Ripple might have the
response to that in terms of the way
it's handled
I'm not sure is this something Nathan
that you could address in terms of the
Department's uh uh yeah so typical
changes yeah so we have a standard
change request form that has the year it
has every single class line and then it
has the requested change so you'll see
class 10 go from a hundred thousand to
two hundred thousand and then it'll have
the net impact so we have those those
documents um and and when we when we
work on that change request that makes
it very clear as far as what's going
where what's increasing what's
decreasing
so representative or if I'm going to
look to you on this I as I remember this
is also Complicated by the idea that the
federal government will bypass the state
altogether and so we wouldn't see some
of those monies that go directly to the
the abortion providers so that says
that's a separate issue and it's not
specifically the abortion providers it's
specifically Planned Parenthood of
Northern New England and I'm pretty sure
that they have not they've not
mistakenly included those here there's
another issue that's involved where
we're between the way the federal
government allocates these funds is in
either three year or five year I think
we just went from a three year to a five
year and in between those two periods if
you have money left and you can within a
period you can roll the money forward
and between periods if with a waiver you
can roll it over a period so we just
came between these two periods and
between 23 and 24 as I understand it so
they got the waiver and they bounced it
over into 24 is the way I understand it
100 correct so so that explains the 2
million is basically whatever the basic
title 10 would have been for the State
of New Hampshire which I think is around
800k but I could be wrong plus that
plus up so 25 then would only be the
amount of the title 10 funding it
shouldn't be the plus up as well
although they'll still be able to roll
the funds forward if they don't get
spent in 24 that's just sort of how the
game how the system works
that's correct thank you
great
um also not only is Family Planning fun
and exciting on this page but we also
have our home visiting Grant which is
the last of the three things I'm going
to come begging for for a prioritized
need our home visiting program has been
our this home visiting program is
federally funded called the maternal
infant early childhood home visiting
program from the federal level locally
this is something called Healthy
Families New Hampshire or Healthy
Families America incredibly important
preventative program really looking at
reducing the number of adverse childhood
experiences and more importantly
supporting young families in the coming
biennium we are going to have an
opportunity to receive additional funds
for home visiting to serve more families
it's been very successful we're maxed
out in the number of families we can
serve but moving forward we will have to
have a match
um to go with that so we are looking for
around 525
000 per year as a match so that we can
serve of additional families in the
coming year I know that's a lot to
consider now but I just wanted to put it
out into the ether as our third and
final prioritized need
uh representative Waller
so I would like to follow in your
footsteps and ask that Mr Ripple put
this on our list of things to come back
to this 525
thousand dollars for a match
and and if I may just make a point of
clarity um just just so you're not
seeing different numbers in our original
agency request this was 1.25 million
each year but we've received it new
information since that point in time so
that's why you will see a discrepancy
between the 525 and the 1.25 so we're
asking for less money
and is this
this 525 for the biennium
annually thank you
yes
great
just Mr Ripple did you it looked like
you were going to say something earlier
did you see something no no I just I
will add that to the list okay if you
see something say something
yeah just
um of the additional 525 most of this
budget is uh for um
um grants for public assistance and
relief would you see it's still going in
there and correct could you talk about
um what kind of thing that is sure so if
you wanted to scoot all the way to slide
28 there's a little more information
there
um this program works with young
families
um from usually prenatal to age three
although we have some additional
dcyf money we've added to that to serve
three to five-year-olds who are it at
elevated risk for child abuse so not
everybody but we've been able to extend
the program a little bit for those that
even at a higher risk but um in general
we provide voluntary home visiting
Services which provide prenatal
education Child Development education
screening for maternal depression really
helping families get connected to places
like their Family Resource Center so
that they are supported in the community
with what we've learned you know one of
the million things we've learned during
the pandemic is the need for social
connection and and this is a program
that supports that sort of social
connection and ultimately the outcomes
are reduced child abuse rates increased
access to things like preventative
screenings for kids one of my favorite
things is we see a decrease in the
number of kids who use the emergency
department for unintentional injuries we
all around supporting parents ability to
parent to their best ability
is the healthy families of America the
contractor that you're working with
Healthy Families America is the name of
the curriculum that we use so it is an
evidence-based curriculum that we put
the money out into the communities each
of those places that are like Family
Resource Centers that participate
um become accredited through that entity
Healthy Families America so you know a
small amount of the money goes back to
healthy America families America but for
in general the contract money goes into
the community to support home visitors
to meet families where they are
foresee having more contractors or
having bigger contracts we uh we
anticipate having
um the same number of contractors likely
we have full Statewide coverage by
County we've got a contractor what the
additional funds and the it would enable
us to do is two things one serve more
families so they would have additional
Staffing costs so that they could serve
more families we've also recognized that
and federally we've recognized that the
way we've funded these has been pretty
low and so the workforce challenge is we
need to actually have a little extra
money in the game to get the the staff
to do the work so this would enable them
to give a little bit more of a bump up
so that people could have something
closer to a livable wage in order to do
this really important community-based
work
uh so you're saying you're underserved
right now because of and do you have an
idea of what percentage of newborns are
not being offered you know what I I can
come back to you with that number right
now the program is focused on Medicaid
eligible families so again you know of
all the families that's still 24 of
families right there rather than all
um there is a sep just to put it out
there there is a separate provision in
the Senate's Omnibus in that bill that
would actually create some work to say
how could you increase home visiting to
families Beyond Medicaid eligible so
that's a separate line of work that'll
happen over there but for the Medicaid
eligible families we're nowhere near the
capacity that we could be
thank you representative Waller
I just wondered how many additional
families you thought the uh
I could probably give that to you after
lunch I know it is in one of my notes
Here I can pull it right up thanks thank
you
all right great so we can move to
um the other items in
um family uh and nutrition is on slide
25 there's a number of activities there
if you have interest and on 26 as well
26 sort of shows that we go to the upper
end with our senior nutrition program so
not only are we talking about moms and
kids but we're also talking about
seniors
um sure
page 977 right
um grants for public assistance line 74
right
we're going from zero to 3.2 million
is this because it was in 102. yeah so
so on on page 977
um
the the class 74 you're referring to
Grants for public assistance relief
um you are seeing uh some movement of
the uh from from the class 102 to
increase that
okay
just moving around
um of note we will be
um at any day now we're expecting a new
what's called a nofo and notice a
funding opportunity for the next
iteration of the opioid data to action
program this opioid surveillance so
um we you know we think this is where
we're going to land
um but we will have a new award
imminently
transfer and there's doj money in there
okay
all right so we can go um slide 27 just
tells you more about WIC you've already
heard me saying the Praises of WIC that
we would love to support WIC Farmers
Market slide 28 talks a little bit about
a home visiting and this is the place
that we would like to have um additional
General general fund not even additional
but to have General funds in order to
serve more families we can go into
infectious disease which is also
um everyone's favorite thing Excuse Me
Miss Tilly just representative one
question here uh with regards to that
healthy families in America where
specifically what page and line item in
the budget is that I will discussion
centered around thank you let me just go
back to that
971 971
thank you
so we will go to
um slide 29 which is infectious disease
I think representative Mooney
971 page number in the line
74. yeah it's it's class 74. yes
thank you and and then are you still on
slide 28
of the color slide 28 is just more
information about home visiting I'm
curious because we have another
postpartum Bill coming around and the
the second bullet jumps out at me yes uh
it says that you know basically uh this
eight week Mark after delivery is a
major demarcation point and right now I
believe the authorization is for two
months so is it is it right to assume
that nearly 20 percent of our moms
uh lose their eligibility before they've
even had a chance to get their their
visit or or do they their eligibility
continue until we do at least one visit
their eligibility
um there is a number in postpartum
individuals that lose their eligibility
eight eight weeks which is why we've had
this as a data point for us to try and
get them in before they lose their
eligibility there's also physiological
reasons why you want to have moms in
there probably at two six and eight
weeks that those are really important
times physiologically that and
clinically that you need to get your
eyes on newly delivered moms
um so again this is a holdover of of a
policy choice that we've made at a
federal level where we lose Medicaid so
we've had a push in some of our
supportive programs to make sure moms
get to those Health Care appointments
and we know this um and we are public
health has been working with Medicaid to
ensure that 12-month postpartum care
because we know really at 8 weeks think
about babies that's when they start not
sleeping through the night moms are
under incredible amount of stress and
what we've seen in our maternal
mortality as you know representative
Edwards we've seen the increased risk
for overdose and suicide post eight
weeks so
um getting expanded medicated or getting
Medicaid coverage postpartum is
incredibly important we have managed
this with the current system by trying
to get as many moms into care as
possible by eight weeks did you have a
question representative I do
sorry this is a naive question so I see
81 on page 28 right of Home visited moms
I'm reading that interpreting that to
mean right 81 of the new new mothers had
someone stop at their door
to visit them at home or is that to just
having an interaction with them whether
it's in a PDF pediatrician's office or
somewhere else so thank you for the
opportunity to clarify that what that is
saying is of the people that participate
in the home visiting program so again a
small number of the overall Medicaid
population of that group 81 of that
group gets to their doctor's office by
eight weeks is that helpful
thank you
sure are you about to get to 29 a.m
whenever you're ready no okay so this is
a good time checkpoint uh representative
nordgren it's noon now
would you like us to to continue as
we're doing to see how far we can get
and we'll postpone a lunch decision for
another 30 minutes or so to see how far
we get or what's your pleasure
okay so how are you doing uh I can go
forever
you seem like you're able to talk
there are many questions do you need
more water or something can we get you
something I'm I'm good so far all right
representative hole thank you Mr chair
page 981 I'm just looking at the
summarization summary for all of this we
can go there right we're going from 28
million and 34 to 39 for each year in
the biennium it looks like most of that
is coming out of federal
um but I don't understand where this
other funds is jumping up by
1.6
um 1.8 million dollars or something if I
got my numbers right almost 2 million so
other funds can include a number of
things in here that is some of our
rebate dollars I believe as well as
things like our newborn screening
program where for every baby that is
born in the state the hospitals purchase
something called a filter paper which is
where you put the screening test on
that's how we fund that those are
another piece that adds into that other
funds
so are these coming from other parts
within DHHS or is this from private
providers in terms
again rebates come from the food per the
food
um in WIC when we may enter into a
contract like with a uh a formula vendor
we get a rebate
um based on the number of piece a number
of food items that we sell we then turn
that money back into the program to
support the program same thing with the
newborn screening that those dollars
come from the hospitals and then we we
have self-sustain the program from those
fees
so they're neither State nor federal
dollars
So within the above lines where do I
find that 1.8 million right the the
general funds is pretty level funded on
page 981 it's it's
reasonably similar to 2023.
um however
it is different than 2022 and maybe
that's part of the variance I don't know
but there's a huge jump in the other
funds
we would have to go back through and
look through each account yeah just to
identify what the discrepancies are we
can certainly follow up with that
information yeah
thank you
Mr chair I I think one of them might be
just the WIC rebate which went from 2.6
to 4 million
uh the amount of rebates here you're
anticipating so
yeah
um if with the pleasure of the chair I
can fill in a couple of questions
um from my trusty folks in the back
who've been helpful to find answers
while I've been up here um so you asked
for the number of suicides I'm pleased
to know that the number I was about to
spit out is correct
um 2020 there was 234 suicides 2021 223
2022 242. so I was about to say around
200 that's the number home visiting
number in 2022 we serve
522 adults with 306 children in 344
households
so again tiny numbers when we consider
the entire Medicaid population everyone
could benefit from home visiting
go ahead
and if I made it just to clarify uh
representative wholes so so on page 981
you see the other funds there in 22. and
then you see the adjusted authorize in
. so that those are the funds that we
actually received so we probably and I
can look this up real quick but we
probably budgeted at a much higher rate
so that's that's what we actually were
able to bring in
the color comment
over time especially with WIC rebates
sometimes we've had to accept money
because we were budgeted too low so
we've just budgeted it high so that we
don't have to keep coming back to you at
fiscal over and over again
thank you for that
as long as I've been doing time checks
we we have a couple of people in the
audience back here did you did you
intend at some point to speak or want to
speak or what what what brings you in
today
okay so they're with you yes yes they're
they're just us I I just didn't know if
anyone was selling tickets to this this
is pretty no one else is interested in
this all right let's let's keep going
okay great so I think we're down to
slide 29 which is infectious disease and
I lost my spot
um
so again our Bureau of infectious
disease fewer accounting units in here
than the previous Bureau that we just
were had we just had Ryan White is the
um work that we do to support people
with HIV those pharmaceutical rebates
are again another other set of funds
that are associated with with HIV care
Disease Control is sort of our larger
disease
um item mosquito control fund and then
if you go to the second page that's
where we look at more of our vaccine and
immunization related funds as well as
STD and HIV prevention
any questions
um I was wondering where Lyme disease
might fit in
um in
um that would generally fall into
Disease Control and the work that we do
within our our larger that's the bigger
catch-all of some of our federal grants
and some of our programs and that's
where Lyme disease as we know Lyme
disease is a reportable condition we
have about 30 reportable conditions that
all need to be sent to
um to the division of Public Health
Services and that is one we certainly
have seen those numbers go up over time
thank you go ahead um it's just I'm I'm
seeing you know some that uh it does
does seem to be growing and also I'm not
sure best practices in terms of early
treatment uh shortly after diagnosis per
CDC guidelines is being properly filed
uh followed including antibiotics like
Dr doxycycline and so um
so I just thought I would bring that up
during this section so if you have any
comments on that yeah no I mean I think
we are seeing this with all the
arborviral
um viruses that we're seeing so whether
it's Lyme disease or other tick-borne or
mosquito-borne illness we're going to
continue to see those go up as our
weather changes
um we will see more
um of these diseases we're just having
longer Springs we have less hard Winters
even though it's you know the individual
weather may not change but as we know
climate has certainly changed um and so
we are prepared to continue to see that
those go up
um as we move forward and we work with
our clinicians to help with those guys
make sure they're following the
appropriate guidelines
so you're six years here's my favorite
question on STDs
what what are what are we going to do in
this budget cycle that we've not yet
done to make sure that public awareness
is increased around the prevalence and
Trends in STDs thank you
um so uh as many in this room know and
certainly the people sitting behind me
know I love to talk about STDs it's one
of you know when I'm not talking about
home visiting I'll just talk about
chlamydia until the cows come home
um so on slides 11 31 and 32 you'll see
that we have this increase
um in gonorrhea and syphilis we have
actually seen a little decrease in
chlamydia but I think that's more a
question of screening because the
physical symptoms of that don't drive
you to the doctor in the same way that
the physical symptoms of gonorrhea and
syphilis get you to the doctor real fast
um but but chlamydia is certainly a
concern because over time especially for
women that can lead to decreased
fertility it's a big sort of Silent
issue that we want people to address to
your question
um I think we have more bandwidth to
address this we are are working next
week actually to make sure that our data
is in a much more transparent place we
currently do monthly reports you can
find them online but they're static
um and they look a little bit like you
know the 30 slide 32 great information
but it's not on our web on our DHHS data
portal over the next biennium we're
going to move that data to be much more
Dynamic and available I think we need to
figure out in terms of prevention one of
the sad things that's happened with the
reduction of Family Planning programs
that we can fund part of their work was
also to really do education around STDs
and we just have fewer people contracted
to do that work so we're going to have
to find new ways to make sure that
individuals especially young adults know
to come in and get screened
actually we have more money to fund the
Family Planning programs we have fewer
contractors willing to take the money
we have a slight difference in semantics
I I would I would just put a finer point
on it that our executive Council has
rejected some contracts that were bid
appropriately
I I don't disagree okay I I I do want us
to to do more to push this information
out to the people that might get scared
and and behave so I I think that's great
and quite frankly we have the bandwidth
to do that as we move you know knock on
wood we have the bandwidth to do that as
we've discussed the same people who do
disease investigation for STDs have been
the people who have been on the front
lines of covid as we've pulled back from
covid we have more space that makes
sense representative hole thank you
you're still ahead of me I'm still I'm
still on page 986 coming through
vaccinations okay so sorry to take you
back
um
in 2022 we had 17 and a half million
spent on vaccinations there's an
estimated 16 for 23 24 and 25 a nice
round number I have no problem with
round number estimates but where will we
before covid because I would suspect
that 17 million dollars also had a chunk
of coveted stuff tied in or not no covet
does not show up in there okay
okay so then why are we
estimating something in a million and a
half less than we spent in 2022
so so that this is a revolving fund
um and and this is our best estimate um
because this is a revolving fund uh we
we don't come back through fiscal for
these funds just given the unique nature
of it based on how it's established
within RSA so so that is our best
estimate at this point in time and
there's fluctuations from year to year
okay and then
so when it says other right source of
funds it falls under revolving funds but
there must be it must come out of the
general at some point so these are these
these are truly other funds the way New
Hampshire ensures that all children
regardless of of insurer has access to
all recommended childhood vaccines is
that the hmos and the commercial
providers all come together and
essentially give us the money to buy the
vaccines we buy the vaccines with those
funds so again it's through the insurers
we come together we buy the vaccines we
distribute it it's just a different way
to ensure that we capture all kids and
no one falls through the cracks with
recommended childhood vaccines okay
thank you
right I think that's everything in
infectious disease you can learn more
about chlamydia and gonorrhea on your
own time
uh we can go into slide 33 which is our
Laboratory
um as well this has two pages some
larger funds and and a couple of smaller
ones but these are the funds that that
support all work at our Public Health
lab and so that includes both
microbiology chemistry and virology so
everything from rabies
to gonorrhea um you know in there as
well as chemistry around water lab we've
certainly heard in the news recently
around the increased detection of radon
in water our water lab does a great job
of helping of uh testing private home uh
well owners that want to have their lab
they're water tested as well as working
with Environmental Services on some of
the other water systems that need to be
tested does this also include any money
spent on laboratory work to support law
enforcement
laboratory that sometimes called the tax
lab that really does a lot of the um or
the work that they do especially around
opioids or substances and other pieces
we work closely with them we partner
with them where needed and um what we do
in public health uh fundamentally with
regard to opioids is we have some new
opioid Federal money that we're using to
be able to do greater testing on not
only the the opioid themselves but sort
of the human element of uh to get an
understanding of what's especially with
poly drug use what's in people's system
so we do a little bit in that space but
very little but the department of safety
has its own lab
so a few years ago there were some
Sensational articles news stories about
um
fraud in Laboratories
government-run Laboratories to where
they weren't doing the sampling or they
were faking the results and do I'm just
curious I'm not accusing anyone but I'm
just curious do we have a systematic way
of doing like an independent audit just
to kind of you know maintain assurance
that that we're running our Labs
properly is that all clear or is that is
um and quality improvement program
within the lab where we're doing
sampling constant sampling to make sure
that we're getting consistent results we
have in fact we just passed a contract
through governor and Council last week
around the system that we use to to
collect all that data and make sure that
our quality improvement and our quality
assurance program is working well I am
100 confident in the work that happens
within our laboratory we have an
extraordinary group of people that are
you know work at the highest in
integrity and and standards to make sure
that what we're doing is correct we use
other Laboratories to sort of con to
test to make sure you know in layman's
term if I get this particular result
does that other laboratory also get the
same result to make sure that we have
quality assurance
I do page 991 so I'm looking at the
total for this department I can see in
section 59 right we're going from
roughly 500 000 a year to 800 that's a
600 000 change over the biennium but I'm
not sure where
I'm quickly seeing effectively a one and
a half million dollar change over 22 an
average of 2023 right 2023 was a
3.02 million and we're up to 3.7 and 3.8
so I I think what I think for first and
and I I will answer all your questions
first um I think it's important to
remember that the numbers that you're
looking at for 2022 2023 are not what
was budgeted 22 is the actual expense
and there's a variety of factors that
feed into that the adjusted authorized
is what was budgeted plus any fiscal or
other carry forward items
um the now the the the class 50 the
temporary sorry excuse me class 59 the
temporary full-time
um we we did add I believe it was a five
additional temporary positions I believe
to meet the continuing increase workload
and then you will also see an increase
in the contract line
um of of uh almost two hundred thousand
dollars there as well I don't know do
you know what the contract was I can't
remember off the top my head which of
the contracts it was
and and I I can follow up with that
information
so is in terms of the Laboratory Testing
is this supporting some of the things
like the Wastewater testing yes yes it
is so
in terms of efficacy of testing waste
water is that a good place to be putting
five additional people I don't think
five additional people are going
directly to Wastewater in fact I can
think of one that is going to to waste
water
um and in terms of efficacy we think
that this is a place um while we're
using it for covid today we're basically
cutting our teeth on the covid work but
um our folks in the laboratory our phds
and our doctors there are really
anticipating that moving forward this is
going to be an area that we see more
growth in we certainly saw in New York
state where they found a pocket of polio
within a community using Wastewater
testing so these are these are
methodologies that we think are going to
be important moving forward and we can
get it right now as we look at covet
thank you
um
all right you can see where I added some
additional data there on slides 35 and
um that talks a little bit both about
our Water Testing Lab a little bit of
biomonitoring that's a program where
we've been specifically thinking about
the elements that end up in your body
those environmental contaminants
um food also we we do a lot of testing
of food in our food emergency response
both from a routine testing of things
like shellfish we also have to have
capabilities in case there's a public
health emergency where someone
intentionally puts things in our food
that should not be there and so we need
to maintain the capacity for that
there's a little bit of information
about Wastewater testing on Slide 36.
So speaking of emergencies we can go
into slide 37 if you would like that is
this is our new Bureau of emergency
preparedness response and Recovery we
call it deeper it's my favorite name of
a bureau the eper bureau
um this Bureau came into our budget in
the last biennium it used to be the
Emergency Services unit used to be
underneath the Commissioner's Office a
biennium ago it was moved into public
health during the pandemic really to
improve the coordination we've been
working well and also just the oversight
because so much of their work is public
health related specific and especially
during the pandemic so we have an
additional we have particular federal
funds in there that are all around
ensuring that we're prepared for
whatever comes next
um in any whether that's radiological or
via a virus there's a fund in there
called the Public Health crisis response
that is a general relief funded
um account so that we can respond Bond
when there's something emergent that
comes up and so it's a it's a small
amount of money but it allows us to act
quickly we use this a little bit of this
money just actually very little bit of
the money um this past year from Monkey
pox for example or mpox as it's now
known because the feds didn't get any
money to us at all until now in fact we
still haven't gotten any money to
address and pox at all so we were able
to use this to activate some of our
partners
um and then finally again we have
radiological emergency response where we
use funds
um from Seabrook in some cases to make
sure that we're ready in case there's
something bad
there
so I want to I want to pick at the
public health emergency preparedness on
on budget book 1001
I I I see that of the 6 million 90 of it
is federal generally yes are is our 500
000 is that uh mandated mandated match
is that a minimum level of effort is
that a it's a mandated match and and
it's a 10 percent match ten percent
all right and so
is there is there an upper limit to what
they're willing to match if we if we put
another 100 000 in there would they
increase we would all be very happy I'm
not particularly concerned about what
I'm not saying we would do it I'm just
asking I I'm not saying that you would
do it either it would be incredibly
helpful this is a place where we
actually run up against our
um our federal grants it looks like
there's lots of money in there but
things like laboratory reagents things
like that are fairly expensive and so um
this is a place where we're counting
pennies to to cover all our bases so
it's just 23 people that just seems like
a whole lot of people to me having
worked in emergency response before so
so it's across a broad range of
activities so these include people in
our infectious disease program that are
ready to be activated so it pays for
some nurses it pays for people in the
laboratory it also pays for the people
who are true like emergency planners so
it's both doers and planners
representable
thank you Mr chair
so back to my earlier discussion on
rents leases Etc right this line is
almost zeroed out relative to this is
is this space covered somewhere else or
is there a way for us to move over to
this
to this fund right some of some portion
of
base at Haze and drive so it's better
covered from the federal side so so the
rents leases
um that it was uh 500 each year
right that doesn't cover much space for
23 people so I'm I'm wondering whether
there's a way to do that I I I don't
believe that that is renting any
building I think it's something smaller
it's photocopier
we do 500. okay so so so kind of along
the lines were representative Edwards
was going right
is this a place where we would be
prudent to actually incr incur a cost in
terms of least rented space that's
currently covered elsewhere in DHHS
somewhere these 23 people have to be
working and then build it back through
this department so there is a match so
that we fund it appropriately
so you don't necessarily see things like
that here we we have a a public
assistance cost allocation plan that
that we utilize internally it's a
several hundred page document it's it's
reviewed by the feds and approves and
and we have a system in place where we
leverage all those federal dollars so
you heard me talk earlier last week
about our new business intelligence
system that we've been working on so
that with a couple of the clicks of a
button that I can quickly show you every
account that's paid for out of the out
of a particular Federal fund you know
Federal fund or or series of them and so
in that Central account where we have
those those rents leases
um included we we are leveraging as many
federal dollars as we possibly can
representative walner did you have a
question
so I just wanted to follow up on a
question that you had about
um the match
are there additional federal dollars
available if we add more match not to my
understanding okay thank you
great
thank you um so slide 39 just gives you
a high level overview of some of the
things that we do within here around
functioning you know we work
um also very closely with Homeland
Security we are responsible for esf8
which is the housing and the health
um component health and medical
um as well as ESF at six which is the
housing components in the homeland
security structure
um this does we do you know in good time
we've had nothing but training and real
work over the pandemic we've done all
this work but someday when we're not
actually doing the work of responding to
an emergency we will get back to
training for when there is a different
emergency it also covers things like rep
which is the radiological training which
we do every year as well because again
no one wants um we want to be prepared
if something ever happened at Seabrook
um slide 40 puts us into our last Bureau
um which is great I think we've flown
right through here
um maybe flown isn't the word this is
our Bureau Bureau of prevention and
wellness again we broke out our
population and Community Health Services
to that family side this is the chronic
disease side and prevention side we have
a number of federal grants in here this
in fact most of this Bureau is 100
federally funded big big chunks or
chunks of federal dollars not as much
General funds and you can see through
um slides 40 and 41 the content area so
I have a couple questions around the
tobacco prevention on pages
178 but on 1008 there's like a million
dollars of federal money and 600 000 in
state funds is is there a match in there
yeah these were those were six hundred
thousand that was dedicated to Tobacco
prevention several bienniums ago and we
have maintained that and we use this
primarily for a lot of our Outreach uh
to adolescents that the These funds were
specifically put in several years ago to
address vaping one of the best news
stories uh is we've you know uh is we've
actually seen that number come down we
were at some point at ridiculously high
rates in high school we're starting to
see that come down okay so the this is
level positions at five we're continuing
five and then there's a fairly
significant jump in uh the federal
dollars for this uh 150 000 on that base
is pretty substantial what what what
what do they think they're getting for
that extra do we know why they're
plusing us up 150 some thousand 160.
so you see what I'm saying it's it's a
date uh you oh wait now in 22 it was
over a million and so compared to 22
it's about the same I let myself look at
23 for a second
all right so let me ask you a different
question
um
what are our metrics this is one of the
programs that has bugged me because I've
talked to predecessors of mine who've
been say they've been asking this for
years and years and years
what are the metrics to know that this
program is worthwhile
sure so one of them is really
utilization of the Quit Line that we do
so and one of the things that we've done
and I don't know exactly the percentages
of this between General and federal but
we've added additional supports just for
adolescents because the way in which you
need coaching to stop your tobacco
dependence it looks very different if
you're a 55 year old woman who smoked
for 30 years versus a 18 year old who's
been vaping so we've differentiated that
way so the metrics around uptake we also
are looking at and you can see this in
the budget briefing book if you want to
look at we are focusing on certain
populations
specifically folks who have behavioral
health issues we know that they smoke it
disproportionately higher levels so
we're working with those with Community
Mental Health Centers to try and see how
we can reduce the number of active
smokers in those populations that's just
a couple examples
to do do we know that there's a
correlation between the money we spend
in this program and actual changes in
Behavior or are we doing that on gut
instinct
you know I think that's the problem with
all Prevention Services it's very hard
to draw an absolute straight line which
is why we measure both process and
outcome so we measure we can measure how
many people particip you know go to the
Quit Line that's a hard number we know
that we pushed that number we did that
through work through advertising but
quite frankly the best way to get that
is to work with our clinical Partners to
make sure that they've got it built into
their emrs that if someone comes in as a
smoker they go through there's some
evidence base around how you get people
to you know the theories of change of
how you think about stopping smoking and
that we can help people where they are
and eventually move them into an
evidence-based quit program we know the
expenses for tobacco use are
extraordinary you know when we think
about all health care we talk about
cancer we talk about heart disease talk
about asthma COPD emphysema all those
costs are on the way end you know way
back end you're going to get that in
long-term care you're going to get that
in in Medicare costs so it's hard for us
to to show show that but we do know that
if you start smoking for example before
you know as a teen you're much likely to
keep smoking for the rest of your life
so I believe all of that I'm just still
looking to see if there's a causation so
so I'm going to tell you a 30-second
story of why I have animus towards this
program
um I got
two years ago I got a call from a mom
and she was telling me how vital this
program was to keep her son from smoking
and since there was a hiccup or
something A disruption in the program
she said that her son had started
smoking so she was saying that this
program would have been vital but it
wasn't available so when I kept talking
to her she was an RN at one of our
academies our academic academies up
north and her job was to to take care of
the health of all of those young
students
but she couldn't control her own son she
said that the government program was
essential for her to have an effective
relationship with her with her own
family and that's the point where I
thought oh my God is this government
program replacing parenting or or
government programs never replace
parenting but they do provide help
provide the conditions to make parenting
easier so it's the reason why we have
policies that you cannot lawfully
purchase cigarettes until you're 18
years old that's part of you know that's
a policy that this and this entity has
put in place because we know that if you
start smoking when you're younger we
know younger people than 18 have smoked
but we've essentially made it harder for
them to do that and that's the sort of
thing that I think this program does is
it changes some social norms
um especially around the work what we've
done around vaping which is saying
um you know big tobacco is lying to you
you're going to be addicted this isn't
you know vaping is has nicotine in it so
it is addictive that's the sort of work
that we do that sets the conditions to
help make it easier for parents to do
their job all right uh thank you
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman would you anticipate an
increase in this particular budget
section if House Bill
639 regulation and legalization of
cannabis passes that's a really
interesting question thank you
um we know I I don't the answer is I
don't know
um we know things like vaping you know
is normalized especially when you're
vaping both cannabis as well as tobacco
we want to minimize that to the best to
our ability it's interesting to your
point earlier representative Edwards we
saw The Vaping numbers come down during
the pandemic when more kids were at home
more often which is of Interest I don't
know that there's a correlation there
but it's interesting to see that as we
have more access to a regulated
commercial product of of cannabis it's
hard you know we see that at we see that
activity normalized in the how household
much like when parents used to smoke
kids used to smoke as well I imagine
cannabis use in the home is going to
drive use of other substances but I
don't know that for sure
representable thank you how do you know
that the numbers dropped during covid
I'm curious what the data set that is
sure so we have something called the
youth risk behavior survey
um it's called yrbs it's a CDC runded
survey it's done in our high schools and
we have 2021 data that was just released
and we have not released it by School
District yet like it's hot off the
presses and we saw that in 2021 there
was a dip in vaping the other concerning
thing was around the increase around
some behavioral health issues that's
what we've been hearing in the media the
piece we're not hearing about yet
certainly in New Hampshire is the dip in
vaping and the dip of alcohol used to be
so is there any correlation between that
data and things like
um
sales through the establishments that
are The Vaping sales in terms of gross
revenue I mean I don't I
I don't know I mean it's hard
and if you're under 18 you're buying
that some illegally in some way whether
someone else is buying it for you or
you're not being carded when you go in
there but I imagine that if you looked
at the revenue you you might see that
but you know the number of the 16 to 18
year olds while it's important certainly
isn't the full number of people who are
vaping so you know more middle-aged
people could have been vaping I'm just
trying to understand the correlation and
was it because they were home and they
weren't with their peers their greater
parental involvement or it is it
supported by other things like sales of
of vaping products I think that that's
more that is information that we've yet
to fully uncover and and look into it's
a great line of inquiry that we just
have not had the time yet to do since
the data just came out we had been
seeing you know a four-year pretty
markets
um Trend upwards of teen vaping and
we're now seeing it you know we're
hoping we've gone over the hill and
we're starting to go back in the right
direction what's causing that we're
we're gonna have to find out more again
many of us can sort of imagine that kids
were at home more and not with their
peers but that's a conjecture I don't
know that for sure
done
um 42 and 43 slides 42 and 43 just tell
you the great work that we've done
around chronic disease worked with great
Partners like the YMCA to do things like
diabetes self-management great program
under the radar that we do slide 43
highlights some new work that we're
doing with EMS in communities and
hospitals called mobile Integrated
Health where we're maximizing the use of
EMS providers to be able to provide some
care when after people come out of the
emergency room for a chronic disease
whether that was an asthma event or a
diabetic event and that we're helping
them with that self-management so that
there are fewer readmissions this is
really promising we've just started this
work in this past year but it looks it
looks great we're excited to see where
it goes and then on slide 44 that's just
our last final plea for some of those
prioritized needs to support families so
that's my
that's it so wait a second you may you
may have ended too quickly on 44. you're
you're saying these are your PR your
priority needs yeah why don't you why
don't you just spend a moment to talk
through these what sure what what's
going on here sure these are what these
so as I noted we have three prioritized
needs in public health one is the
overtime for food I didn't add that
there it feels technical in nature we
just need an overtime line that's
manageable for food protection what
slide 44 really talks about is the
combination of both home visiting and
and WIC these are places where we put
interventions with families that are
most at need at really vulnerable times
we know um if we think about WIC we've
got going to see the unwind as um I'm
sure director lippman has talked about
and and other folks at
um around the fewer SNAP benefits that
are going to be available to families
fewer other hard concrete supports we
know that WIC is going to be more
important now well certainly than it was
in the past few years and so we want to
make sure that we have the opportunity
that not only can they use their WIC
benefit as it is right now for the
grocery store but that we could have an
opportunity for them to leverage
additional federal dollars to have extra
access to fresh fruits and veggies
through farmer's market so so I'm not
seeing dollar amounts yeah do you have
uh intended targets that you'd like us
to consider and how will we know what
those numbers are the original
prioritize needs that we that we
submitted it was three hundred thousand
dollars of General funds in state fiscal
year 24 and 300 000 in state fiscal year
25 as well
asking for is less than the original
request which was 1.25 million we're
down to 5.25 K 525k per year because we
found we have better numbers to work
with now and then
um just the 20 25 000 in overtime those
are the three dollar figures okay and I
noticed on page 40 that we have a wise
woman program and I'm just wondering can
we find no wise men anywhere
a sexist would say
representative Paul thank you chairman
so
um
I'm looking my background is in is in
the medical diabetic domain so I'm
hypersensitive to that
um that field
and
in watching the how covid played out
unfortunately a number of patients did
not
handle covered well one and didn't make
it throw but we have seen long coveted
impacting the endocrine system impacting
people pushing them into the diabetic
the secondary diabetic market right for
either hemo or peritoneal dialysis
how do we get ahead of this and start
talking about the importance of vitamin
D maybe I was naive but I did not
realize and I would consider myself
rather well read how valuable vitamin D
was to address and help prevent some of
the side effects both long covid
as well the other things how do we get
ahead of that now in terms of a budget
priority
most people are vitamin D deficient
we can't do anything we're at the 40th
latitude Mark right we
half the year we don't have Sun
um
so how do we start what can the
department do to better prepare our
citizens because
yes we used to drink lots of vitamin D
infused milk guess what like people
aren't drinking as much Dairy anymore
right especially when you get to the
older populations so there is no place
to write in their their typical diet to
deal with this yet it's hyper it is
really crucial to weathering various
where various viruses
what can you do as a department and how
do we make sure that happens sure so I
can say certainly
with now we work closely again with
Partners like you see on C on the slide
with YMCA Granite YMCA to really focus
focus on diabetes self-management
um and in that is a focus on nutrition
and so I think that's a place that we
can add additional information and
supporters around nutrition as well as
physical movement you know those are the
areas that we know regardless you know
certainly for pre uh whether you're
pre-diabetes straight into whether you
have more advanced disease we know that
just taking care of those two things
getting nutrition under control and
getting your physical activity under
control we can help create better
outcomes of the long in the long term so
I think that that's a place that we can
provide additional information we're
certainly going to always look to CDC
and to our other clinical partners and
you know I know just enough to be
dangerous but certainly
um you know Dr Ballard and Dr Chan help
us in those spaces but nutrition is of
Paramount concern and we do that through
these
localized self-management programs that
have local have coaches to help people
to work through through their own
individual issues
thank you representative a question no
no representative solorski thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um when you referred to three hundred
thousand dollars to meet a priority need
was that the nutrition ask yes that is
the nutritionist okay thank you a quick
follow-up
um there was a bill that I believe was
defeated last week I just was
frantically looking on my phone to find
the number
um but I believe it had to do with
expanding WIC access to farmers markets
was that a similar program that you
would have been interested in yes so
essentially
um there was certainly legislation that
would have put that money into this
budget we know that for many reasons
that didn't move through the house we're
still very interested in expanding
access to fresh fruit and vegetable for
the Wic population thank you
so I'm not seeing any other questions I
think you've marched through your slide
deck for the day okay so let's talk
about tomorrow uh I see on our calendar
that we have the division of Public
Health continued tomorrow what what what
what does that mean
that was in the calendar but Janet sent
around to revision public health is done
today and tomorrow you have Behavioral
Health only starting at 10 o'clock so we
still have we have a behavioral health
and it's been properly noticed and it's
at 10 o'clock tomorrow yes okay
um say what location
and and then our location's not here
tomorrow is it I think it's in room 104.
that sounds right let me just look that
it's fun okay
so not soon
so miss Tilly once again very impressive
performance that you you have a
tremendous grasp of a tremendous amount
of detail I appreciate it I always
appreciate your responsiveness if not
your answers but but but no you you
really you're really very good and we're
lucky to have you there and um Mr White
just you don't know but we were chatting
the amount of detail that you've had to
master in the last year to come up to
speed and to be so so good at providing
sort of a top-down view after you've had
to like wrestle in the mud with the
details is is really excellent it's very
nice work I I would give all credit to
the team that's behind me so
well they're all nodding
they took credit so so there's that did
you have something represent a hole I
concur with your comments I wanted when
you're done to talk about HB 49 not
relative to the bill but to something
I'm handing out oh okay I'm just trying
to let these folks go
um is there any comment from the
audience Ms Landry you've sat here all
morning you got anything for us
okay
okay well with that you all are
dismissed and go enjoy a nice lunch
thank you
uh as a comment I I I think the division
is doing a good job of like once you
start asking questions to just go ahead
and continue to stay on the flow and
that is an unusual thing compared to the
way some committees work I I think it's
working for us so I I would like to
continue doing that instead of coming
back every time I just think it
interrupts the flow to do that
um
we have a request to talk about HB 49
for a moment this is all very informal
because that bill is now with a full
finance committee
I'm going to pass out a document that I
found that talks about this you know
before you do that I I what do you
what's your advice should I close the
hearing we just had this and this is uh
this is not a publicly noticed thing
we're about to do I'm just handing out
something okay so we're not going to
discuss it and okay
so not hb49 is not on the calendar for
today
I don't know go ahead give me an
interpretation it's been changed since
then it was no longer in the calendar
today but if you're only handing around
the document I I think it's fine so I'm
going to close the work session of
division three
um relative to the public health and we
can I don't think we need the cameras on
anymore because you're just handing out
I'm just hitting at a document that I
found that deals with the relative costs
for juveniles and it